ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAND BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER FOR THAT
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER [inaudible]
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY OSHA
FROM NEXT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
DURING THE SUMMER BREAK WE LIKE
TO RECOMMEND CREATING COMPLETELY
AND SCHEDULED MOMENTS.
PERHAPS EVEN A WHOLE DAY OR TWO
SUCH AN SCHEDULED TIME IS KNOWN
TO HELP WITH ARE MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING.
THAT'S GREAT TIME TO BE WITH
PEOPLE SO CLOSE THAT WE CAN BE
COMFORTABLE TOGETHER IN SILENCE.
MAYBE CAR ABOUT A LONG MOMENT
WITH NO AGENDA OR LIST OF THINGS
TO DO.
SOME OF THE FONDEST MEMORIES MY
HUSBAND BOB AND I HAVE.
OUR WHEN WE HAVE BEEN BE ENTERED
THROUGH AN SCHEDULED DAYS WITH
NO DESTINATION IN NO AGENDA.
OUR LIVES BECOME OPEN TO
DISCOVERING NEW PLACES
INTERESTING PEOPLE AND UNIQUE
SHOPS AND RESTAURANTS.
WE'VE DONE THIS IN MANY PLACES
WE TRAVELED IN THE WORLD.
IN A THERE'S ALWAYS PROVED TO BE
A RELAXING ADVENTURE.
SPENDING AN ENTIRE DAY WITH
SOMEONE SO CLOSE THAT WE CAN BE
TOGETHER IN SILENCE.
REMINDS US TO NOT TAKE FOR
GRANTED ARE SPECIAL FRIENDSHIP.
WITH LESS TALKING MORE LAUGHTER
WE QUIETLY REMEMBER AGAIN WHAT
IS REALLY OF VALUE IN LIFE.
IS NOT THE THINGS WE OWN OR
POSSESS THEY GIVE MEANING TO OUR
LIVES.
IT WILL ALWAYS BE THE PEOPLE WE
LOVE.
THEY GIVE MEANING AND PURPOSE TO
EACH DAY.
SO DURING THE SUMMER BREAK A
HEAD.
LET'S ALL TRY TO CREATE
COMPLETELY AND SCHEDULED MOMENTS.
TO BE WITH FAMILY IN DEAR
FRIENDS.
SUCH AN SCHEDULED.
WILL HELP US TO REMEMBER AGAIN
WHAT IS REALLY OF VALUE IN
LIVING EACH DAY.
NUMBER ONE IN A SIEVE WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER BLOOM.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY JULY THIRD
TWENTY NINETEEN THE SOMETHING
THAT AT SEVEN AM ON BUT JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIRTY
FIRST DISTRICT PRESIDING CHIEF
COOKIE DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND LOUIS
READING THE BALLING REPLACED ON
THE MORNING MISTER CALDERON
MOVES.
AND MISS FLORES SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY IRWIN AND
QUIRK SILVA AS WELL AS MR CHOW.
TO SPEAK UNDER GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RESCIND THE ACTION
WHERE BY ON JULY EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRED IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ON AB TEN SEVENTY
NINE SANTIAGO AND REQUEST THAT
THE BILL BE RETURNED TO THE
SENATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO WITHDRAW
SB ONE TEN SB ONE ELEVEN FROM
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO
TAKE UP THE BILL TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
MR FLOOR FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE
WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS CONSENT AND
ASK FOR ROLL CALL VOTE MR FLORA
IS WITHHOLDING THIS IS A ROLL
SUSPENSION MOVED BY MISTER
CALDERON SECONDED BY MISTER
GIBSON MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL.
VOTE ON SUSPENSION OF THE RULES
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORA NO.
THIS CALL AROUND ASKING FOR AN
I..
AND MR FLORA NO MEMBERS THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL.
TALBOT EYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY
SEVEN THE ONE DAY WAITING PERIOD
FOR CONCURRENCE ITEMS. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN TO TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR TODAY.
THIS FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR THE
MYSTERY WE WILL HOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT ASK FOR ROLL CALL VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER FLOOR AS AGAIN
WITHHOLDING MISTER CALDERON
MOVES AND MISTER GIBSON SECONDS
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I. IN
MISTER FLORA NO MISTER CALDERON.
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND
MISTER FLORA NOW.
TAKES.
FORTY ON THE RULES SUSPENSION
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY SIX KNOWS.
THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON AGAIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY EIGHT I AM GIVING A
ONE DAY NOTICE TO REMOVE ITEM
ELEVEN SB SIX EIGHTY WHY COUNTY
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
CLERK WILL NOTE.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM NINE NINETY
EIGHT SB FOUR SEVEN NINE ATKINS
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CLERK WILL AGAIN NO.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE ITEM NINETY FOUR SB
FOUR OR FIVE ARCHULETA TO THE
NECK TO FILE AS WELL AS ITEM.
NUMBER ONE THIRTEEN SB SIX
EIGHTY ONE STERN.
CLERK WILL NOTE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE.
DOCTOR CHOI.
FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
.
MEMBERS MAY I HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR GUESTS HAVE NOW
ARRIVED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM
MY DESK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS -- WITH US TODAY I AM
HONORED TO INTRODUCE A VETERANS
AND THE POPE BRUCE HEART
RECIPIENTS UP TO THIS UPGRADE
CHAMBER.
MANY OF ALL THIS STUFF VETERANS
SO HAVE A TRAVELED THE FROM
ACROSS THIS STATE. TO COME HERE
AND THE RECOGNIZE SO THE COMING
POPULAR HOT DAY ON AUGUST
SEVENTH.
IN THE REAR OF THE UPPER CHAMBER
AND THE WITH ME -- WE ARE JOINED
THE BY -- JOSEPH IN KELLER.
PAGE THREE OUT OF OF THE YEAR
FOR CALIFORNIA SOME MILITARY
ORDER OF THE PURPLE HEART.
JOHN LOGAN.
THE PASTOR COMMANDER FOR
CALIFORNIA MILITARY ORDER OF A
PURPLE HEART.
AND MISTER CHARLES ANDERSON THE
JUNIOR VICE COMMANDER FOR
CALIFORNIA SO MILITARY ORDER OF
THE PURPLE HEART.
JOSEPH IN KELLER JOIN THE UNITED
STATES SO THEREFORE SO IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND THE
SERVER IN THE SIXTY EIGHT L.
MEDICAL LAW EVACUATION SQUADRON.
SHE COMPLETED THE MULTIPLE
DEPLOYMENTS.
SPENDING FROM SAUDI ARABIA.
BOSNIA.
FORMAN AND GERMANY IN SUPPORT OF
OPERATIONS IN IRAQ.
AFGHANISTAN AND THE MANY OF THE
LOCATIONS THIS.
IS BOASTING MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED THE MISHAP FREE
FLYING HOURS.
JOSEPH AND CARED FOR OUR NATIONS
SO WOUNDED WARRIORS SO.
DURING THEIR FLIGHT START TO
MEDICAL STATIONS ALL AROUND THE
WORLD.
JOSEPH IN HERSELF FOR BEING
INJURED IN A TERRORIST ATTACK
WAS HONORED DON'T WITH THE COST.
WITH HER -- STANDING TWENTY
THREE YEARS OF US SERVICE -- AND
THE HER AMAZING VOLUNTEER AT
FOUR SO HEARING IN CALIFORNIA.
SERVING OUR SERVICE MEMBERS ARE.
AS THEY EXIT THE SERVICE.
JOSEPH AND WAS JUST ELECTED THE
BY THE MILITARY.
ORDER OF THE PURPLE HEART.
AS OF PICTURE OUT OF THE YEAR.
FOR OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
JOSEPH IN COLOR.
AND THE VETERANS SO.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
THEN ALSO UP IN THE GALLERY.
UNDERSTAND THE PURPLE HEART.
MEDAL IS A GIVEN.
NOT AS AN ACHIEVEMENT.
BUT BUILT ON HONOR OF OUR SECOND
SACRIFICE.
WHY THE PUBLIC HOTEL MEDAN OR
REGIONALLY DESIGNED BY YOUR
PRESIDENT?
I HAVE A SAMPLES HERE.
OUR DREAM THOUGH WITH THE LIKE
TO HOLDING A BRONZE SO HOT.
WITH YOUR PAGE READ OF A PRESS
IN WASHINGTON.
SO -- SMALLER DENOTE SO THE
HIGHEST THE RESPECT AND HONOR AS
WE WE AS A COUNTRY CAN -- BEST
TOLD TO OUR HEROES.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME.
IN WELCOMING HE WAS MY SON
.
WE ARE MOVING TO THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING BURGLARY.
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT SIX SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY FIVE THREE EIGHTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS TO AWAIT 227-307-1292
592-713-89390 ONE FOR THIRTY SIX
FOUR NINETY SIX FIVE SEVENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE SEVEN EIGHTY ONE FOR
THIRTY EIGHT WITH THE MOMENT.
SIX FORTY FOUR FOUR THIRTY NINE
WITH THE MEMONS ONE FORTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS TO SEVENTY THREE
WITH THE MOMENT SEVEN SIXTEEN
WITH THE MEMONS. FOR SIXTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS TWO OH SIX WITH
THE MEMONS THREE TWENTY THREE
WITH A MOMENT SIX OH SIX WITH
THE MEMONS. SIX OH NINE WITH THE
MOMENT SIX SEVENTY NINE WITH A
MOMENT SIX NINETY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO FORTY WITH A
MOMENT. FIVE FORTY THREE FORTY
TWO WITH THE MEMON SIXTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS ONE NINETY WITH
THE MEMONS TO SIXTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO FORTY SEVEN WITH
THE MOMENT. TWO SIXTY TWO WITH
THE MEMONS FOR SIXTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS SIX THIRTY TO AT THE
MOMENT AND SEVEN FORTY FOUR WITH
THE MOMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO MOVED TO THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
ASKING CURRENTS IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP.
FILE ITEM.
FORTY SIX THIS IS AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR FILE AND FORTY
SIX A. B. TEN FIFTY FOUR HOLDEN.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING NUMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO CLAIM THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION AS YOUR
HOLDEN MISTER HOLDING YOU MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR WILL PAVE THE
WAY. FOR A VERY IMPORTANT
CHAGES AND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
IN ADDRESSING WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE HERE TODAY 2%.
TEN FIFTY FOUR NOT JUST BECAUSE
OF THE IMPACT.
OF WILDFIRES ON OUR STATE.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE INCREDIBLE
DEVASTATION CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES HAVE INFLICTED ON THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
THE COST TO TO CODE TO CUSTOMERS.
AND THE IMPACT ON SOLVENCY OTHER
PROVIDERS A POWER FOR ALL OF US.
CLIMATE CHANGES CREATED A NEW
REALITY.
UNDER THE WILDFIRES IN THE STATE.
THE STATE'S FIRE SEASON AND AS I
ALMOST YEAR ROUND.
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ACRES OF CALIFORNIA WILD LANDS
ARE CLASSIFIED AS UNDER VERY
HIGH.
OR EXTREME FIRE THREAT.
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION THAT'S ELEVEN MILLION
PEOPLE LIVE IN THAT HIGH RISK
AREA.
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE IS
IGNITING AN EXCESSIVE BUILDUP OF
DRY BRUSH.
FROM POUR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IN SOME AREAS BUT INCREASING
OCCURRENCES OF HIGH WINDS.
AND LOW HUMIDITY IS INCREASING
CONTACT BETWEEN UTILITY LINES
AND TREES BECAUSE IN A CONDITION.
EXACERBATING THE FURTHER BY DEAD
AND DYING TREES [inaudible]
THE RESULT. FIFTEEN OF THE
TWENTY MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
HAVE OCCURRED SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND TEN OF THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES HAVE OCCURRED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
WHETHER THE UTILITY WAS APPROVED
MANAGER.
OF ITS EQUIPMENT OR NEGLIGENT
OPERATOR.
UTILITY OPERATOR EXPOSURE TO
GREATER LIABILITY FROM
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
IS BECOMING THE NORM.
AND MORE OF OUR NEIGHBORS THE
VICTIMS OF THE DEVASTATION.
COSTS EXCEEDING INSURANCE
PROTECTION.
DOWNGRADING OF CREDITWORTHINESS
AN INCREASING POTENTIAL FOR
BANKRUPTCY AS COMPROMISE THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE SAFE.
RELIABLE AND COST EFFECTIVE
POWER TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR WILL PAVE THE
WAY FOR UNPRECEDENTED SAFETY
INVESTMENTS BY THE I. O. USE.
WITHOUT PROFITS FOR SHAREHOLDERS.
FOUR CHAU USED TO BE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR WHILE FIRE SAFETY
RECORD.
AND PERFORMANCE AND PROTECT
CUSTOMERS AND TAXPAYERS FROM
HOLY BEARING THE COST.
OF THESE JUST DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES.
THIS BILL.
ALONG WITH SB.
ONE ELEVEN WILL FACILITATE
CUSTOMER ACCESS TO SAFE.
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE POWER BY
PROVIDING A DURABLE SOLUTION TO
THE PROBLEMS ARISING FROM
UTILITY BECAUSE WILDFIRES.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES A NEW
WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION
ADDITIONALLY WITHIN THE CPUC.
NO LATER THAN JANUARY TWENTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
DIVISION WILL BE TRANSFERRED TO
THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SAFETY.
WITHIN THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
THE BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES
PROCEDURES STANDARDS APPLICABLE
TO CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE.
PROCEEDINGS AND CREATE A NEW
PRUDENT MANAGER STANDARD.
AND ESTABLISH A WILDFIRE FUNDING
MECHANISMS TO CAPITALIZE THE
WILDFIRE FUN.
THIS PACKAGE OFFERS A DURABLE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEMS ARISING
FROM UTILITY BECAUSE WILDFIRES
IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH NO INCREASE IN ELECTRIC
RATES FOR CUSTOMERS FROM WHAT
THEY ARE TODAY.
THE PACKAGE PROVIDE CERTAINTY
FOR CUSTOMERS WHOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE FIXED.
BY THE BILL IT PROVIDES
CERTAINTY FOR THE MARKETS TO
PREVENT THE UTILITIES
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN THE SOUTH.
AND PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR FIRE
VICTIMS.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON THIS BILL AND IN CONCURRENCE.
INCIDENT AMENDMENTS AND
IMMEDIATELY AND ROLL AND
TRANSMIT TO THE GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MS BURKE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
IT SIMPLY ISN'T ENOUGH TO CREATE
A FUND FOR FUTURE FIRES.
WITHOUT THE INCREASE IN SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS FOR UTILITIES THIS
BILL WOULD REALLY ONLY SERVE AS
A TEMPORARY FIX TO WHAT HAS NOW
PROVEN TO BE.
AN ONGOING PROBLEM.
AND TO ADDRESS WILDFIRES IN THE
STATE MUST BE COMPREHENSIVE AND
RESULT IN REDUCING CATASTROPHIC
FIRES FROM OCCURRING IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
WITH REGARD TO THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF UTILITIES I
USE LOVE TO SPEND FIVE BILLION
IN AGGREGATE ON FIRE SAFETY AND
MITIGATION OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS.
AND SHAREHOLDERS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO EARN A RATE OF RETURN
OUR PROFIT FROM THIS INVESTMENT.
ENCOURAGING INCREASED WELFARE
SAFETY SPENDING AND HIGHER
UTILITY SAFETY STANDARDS THAT
REDUCE THE OCCURRENCE OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
WILL RESULT IN SAVINGS TO THE
STATE AND TO THE CONSUMER.
ADDITIONALLY IF THIS BILL
SUCCESSFULLY REDUCES FUTURE FIRE
RELATED FINANCIAL RISK UTILITY
CREDIT RATINGS CAM REMAIN STABLE
AND EVEN IMPROVE.
ACCORDING TO THE LA LOW.
EVERY TIME THE BOND RATING
AGENCIES DOWNGRADE THE UTILITIES
THERE IS A CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN THE COST OF
BORROWING FOR THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS.
WHICH RESULTS IN INCREASED RATE
INCREASES THIS IS BECAUSE OF OUR
MONEY IS GOING TO SERVICE DEBT.
IN ADDITION TO SAVING CONSUMER
MONEY THIS BILL TAKES STEPS TO
DISH CREASE THE CHANCES OF
FUTURE FIRES.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR CREATES A
SAFETY CERTIFICATION WITHIN THE
NEW CREATED WHILE FIRE SAFETY
DIVISION AND ADVISORY BOARD.
THAT REQUIRES UTILITIES TO TIE
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION TO SAFETY
PERFORMANCE CREATE A SAFETY
COMMITTEE WITHIN THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
COMPLY WITH THEIR WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS AND PASS A
SAFETY CULTURE ASSESSMENT.
FURTHERMORE THE BILL WE'RE
CREATING NEW PRUDENT STAND
MANAGER STANDARD THAT IS ALIGNED
WITH THE FOR STANDARD TO PROVIDE
MORE CLARITY TO THE UTILITIES.
I TO JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
WELFARE SAFETY VISION WILL BE
TRANSFERRED OUT OF THE PC.
AND INTO THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY WHICH WILL HELP ASSURE
THAT ALL LIKE TRIPLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS REVIEWED AND
ASSESSED BY SPECIALIST.
FOCUSING ON DEVELOPING BEST
PRACTICES FOR WILDFIRE REDUCTION.
THE ADVISORY BOARD WILL BE
COMPRISED OF EXPERTS IN FIRE
PREVENTION AND SAFETY WILL BE
MORE NIMBLE TO RESPOND TO
CHALLENGES AS THEY ARISE.
THE PROVISIONS OF AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR AND IT'S CAMPAIGN BILLS
WILL ALLOW YOU TO LEAST OFFER
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE POWER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT ENDEAVOR
TO MINIMIZE AND PREVENT UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRES FROM HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AS A RESULT OF THE RECENT
WILDFIRES THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
FAMILIES LOST THEIR HOME.
I'M MORE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
THERE'LL FOR THEIR LIVES TO
REGAIN A SENSE OF NORMALCY.
OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS A STATE TO
DEVELOP A SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE DESTABILIZING EFFECTS OF
THESE WILDFIRES ON ALL PARTIES
CONTINUES TO GROW.
ESPECIALLY AS WE HEAD INTO THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FIRE
SEASON.
MEMBERS MAKE NO MISTAKE HOUSING
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR IS A PIVOTAL
STEP BUT IT IS NOT THE LAST STEP.
WE STILL HAVE MANY MORE ISSUES
TO CONTEND WITH.
THERE ARE THOSE IN THIS ROOM WHO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT WHAT TO DO
NEXT TO ADDRESS THE OTHER
OUTSTANDING ISSUES FACING
VICTIMS.
THOSE WHO WISH TO RETURN TO
THEIR HOMES AND HOW BEST TO
ADDRESS THINGS LIFE RELIEF FOR
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY LARGE
ENERGY USERS HOME HARDENING.
UNDER INSURANCE ASSURANCE
AVAILABILITY ALL STILL WITH EYES
TOWARDS THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN VICTIMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
OPEN TO THOSE ISSUES ITEMS AND
WE WILL BE CONTINUING TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS. FOR THOSE WHO
SAY WHY NOW [inaudible]
WHY TODAY?
I SAY I HAVE SEEN THE COST OF
INACTION.
AND WE HAVE ALL SEEN THE
DEVASTATION.
I'VE SAID ALL ALONG WITH THE
FOCUS OF OUR EFFORT SHOULD BE ON
THE PAST FEW AND FUTURE VICTIMS.
AND I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
APOLOGIZE TO THOSE WHO LOST
THEIR HOMES AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
THESE ARE BURDENS THAT WE ALL
PAY FOR NOT TAKING PREVENTIVE
MEASURES THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
DEMANDED LONG IN ADVANCE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS AND MONTHS WHO HAVE BEEN
OUT OF THEIR HOME FOR OR TWO
OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED DAYS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE WITH THEIR LOVED ONES.
FORCED TO LISTEN AS THE FIRE
OVERTOOK THEM.
AND ENDED THEIR LIVES.
WE BEAR SOME RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THAT.
AND TO NOT ACT TODAY WOULD BE
UNCONSCIONABLE.
SO WE MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO
TAKE ACTION.
AND THIS IS AN ACTION IN WHICH
WE REQUIRE ACCOUNTABILITY NOT
JUST FROM US BUT FROM THE
UTILITIES ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
BEHAVE POORLY.
A LOT HAS GONE INTO THIS.
I WANT TO THANK THE JOINT AND CO
AUTHORS FOR THEIR DEDICATION
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF TO
AN ISSUE THAT HAS NO SIMPLE OR
EASY SOLUTION.
YES THIS FINAL PRODUCT IS FAIRLY
NEW BUT WE HAVE SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS DAYS AND WEEKS AND MONTHS
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES. THIRTY
SECONDS OVER THOSE IN OPPOSITION
OR THE NEWSPAPER TRYING WITH THE
WAY THAT WE HAVEN'T PUT TIME AND
EFFORT IN THIS YOU ARE WRONG.
MEMBERS I WENT TO PARIS AND SAW
THE DEVASTATION I SAW YOUNG KIDS
WERE NOT ONLY RECOVERING FROM
TRAUMA BUT ALSO AFRAID THEY WILL
NEVER GO BACK HOME.
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO ACT.
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THIS IS OUR JOB.
WE WERE SENT TO SACRAMENTO TO
MAKE HARD DECISIONS.
I KNOW THIS WON'T BE AN EASY
VOTE FOR SOME OF YOU.
BUT IT IS THE RIGHT.
ONE IT'S A VOTE THE CAN PROTECT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
BECOMING VICTIMS NOT ONLY THE
DEVASTATION AND DESTRUCTION THE
WILDFIRES CAN CAUSE.
BUT THE UNPREDICTABILITY OF
UTILITY COSTS AS WELL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN IBM.
DAVIS BURKE MISSED GRAYSON YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
REFERENCE TO AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR IN THE AFTERMATH
OF THE ROOT OF THE WILD FIRES
THAT TRAGICALLY BURN THROUGH OUR
STATE.
I BELIEVE THAT WE AS POLICY
MAKERS MUST HAVE AT LEAST THREE
PRIORITIES TO GUIDE US AS WE
EMBARK ON TAKING ANY LEGISLATIVE
ACTION. ONE THAT THE FAMILIES
VICTIMIZED BY THESE FIRES
RECEIVE THE ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED. TO
ENSURING THAT RATE PAYERS ARE
PROTECTED IN THREE MAKNG SURE
THAT RANK AND FILE EMPLOYEES ARE
NOT BEARING THE BURDEN OF BLAME
THAT BELONGS ON THE BACKS.
OF CORPORATE EXECUTIVES WHO MADE
DECISIONS THAT PUT OUR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK OF
EXPERIENCING THESE MEGA FIRES.
THIS LEGISLATION STRIKES AS
CLOSE TO A BALANCE AS POSSIBLE
AND ALSO ENSURES.
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE OUR
PROGRESS TOWARDS REACHING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION TARGETS
HOWEVER WE MUST NOT LOSE SIGHT
OF HOW ENERGY PRICES INSTABILITY
AFFECT OUR BROADER ECONOMY.
ENERGY COST HAVE A KNOCK ON
INSTITUTIONAL USERS OF ENERGY.
AND I APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
OF ALL VARIETIES TO WE'VE GOT TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE
NEED TO STABILIZE UTILITIES.
I DO ASK HOWEVER THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN A ROBUST
DISCUSSION WITH THE LARGE USERS
OF ENERGY.
SUCH THE LIKE OUR STATE'S
MANUFACTURERS TO BE ABLE TO FIND
LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
HELP THEM REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN
A VERY CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT.
BOTH NATIONALLY AND GLOBALLY I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY AND I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING MORE ON THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES IN THE FUTURE.
THANKS GRAYSON MS LAMONT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM A
DISTRICT IMPACTED BY THE THOMAS
FIRE AND SOMEONE WHO DID NOT
SUPPORT SB NINE A ONE LAST YEAR
I RISE TO SPEAK ON AB. TEN FIFTY
FOUR TWENTY TWO MONTHS AGO THE
THOMAS PRIOR FIRE BROUGHT
DEVASTATION TO MY DISTRICT ON A
SCALE THAT HAD NEVER BEEN SEEN
BEFORE.
BUT THAT WAS JUST ONE OF
NUMEROUS FIRES THAT HAS CHANGED
THE WAY WE LIVE.
WHEN THE ISSUE OF WILDFIRES AND
NATURAL DISASTERS CAME BEFORE US
ON THE FLOOR?
I FIND MYSELF THINKING OF THE
COUNTLESS VICTIMS THAT HAVE YET
TO BE MADE WHOLE.
WHEN I TAKE THESE VOTES I THINK
OF THE VICTIMS?
IN MY DISTRICT AND THE FUTURE
POTENTIAL VICTIMS.
I AM SUPPORTING AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR BECAUSE IT IS A FIX THAT
COMES CLOSEST TO PROTECTING
WILDFIRE VICTIMS RATE PAYERS AND
HOLDING UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES UTILITIES TO
MAKE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ENSURE VICTIMS
CLAIMS ARE SETTLED IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
AND SPECIFICALLY PROHIBITS THESE
COSTS FROM BEING PASSED DOWN TO
REPAIRS.
IT HELPS REDUCETHE OCCURRENCE
OF CATASTROPHIC FIRES BY HOLDING
UTILITIES TO A HIGHER SAFETY
STANDARD AND REQUIRES THEM TO
TAKE ACTIVE STEPS TO ACHIEVE
THOSE STANDARDS INCLUDING.
STRENGTHENING INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HIGHLIGHTING
MANAGEMENT'S ROLE IN FOSTERING A
SAFETY CULTURE.
IT INCENTIVIZE IS UTILITIES TO
ESTABLISH AN EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION STRUCTURE THAT
PROMOTES SAFETY AS A WHOLE AND
SHIFT EXECUTIVES FOCUS TO MAKING
DECISIONS BASED ON SAFETY AND
NOT PROFIT.
AND ITS STABILIZERS REPAIRS
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR AT LEAST THE
NEXT TEN YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE KNOWN MY
COMMUNITY I'VE BEEN I'VE NOT
KNOWN MY COMMUNITY WITHOUT
WILDFIRES WHICH MEANS THAT IS
ONLY A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE WE
EXPERIENCE THE DESTRUCTION OF
ANOTHER. ONE FOR THIS REASON I
DO NOT TAKE THIS VOTE LIGHTLY.
SINCE DECEMBER FOURTH OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I HAVE SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THINKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES
DISCUSSING THESE ISSUES IN
COMMITTEE IN SMALL GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUAL CONVERSATION.
THIS MEANS WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
MY DISTRICT AND THE ENTIRE STATE
NOT ONLY TO DATE AND FOR YEARS
TO COME IS IMPORTANT IN MY
DELIBERATION.
THIS BILL PROVIDES FUTURE WHILE
FIRE VICTIMS BETTER CONFIDENCE
THAT DESPITE THE LOSS AND
DEVASTATION THERE IS RELIEF
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM GET BACK
ON THEIR FEET.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS EMMA.
DOCTOR WOULD.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR THE WILDFIRE
TRAGEDIES THAT HAVE PLAYED -- TO
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
NEED OUR HELP WHEN THEY NEED IT
NOW.
WE WANT -- TO MOST IMPORTANTLY
MAKE SURE VICTIMS OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
FIRES ARE COMPENSATED.
WE WANT TO PROTECT RATE PAYERS
AND WE WANT TO STABILIZE THE AND
UTILITY MARKET AND I'M THANKFUL
TO OUR COLLEAGUES -- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD FOR
THE NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION I
WORK ON THIS -- THE GOVERNOR'S
WORK ON THIS -- AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE THAT WE DO
THIS.
IT'S A HUGE STEP FORWARD.
AND MORE IS NEEDED -- TO PROTECT
PEOPLE IN THE FUTURE I TO HAVE
LIVED THE WILDFIRES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN ACTUALLY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
WITH -- WHEN THE FIRE STARTED IN
LAKE COUNTY -- I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT ONE ONLY ONE IN TEN FIRES
WILDFIRES IS STARTED.
BY UTILITY. NINE OUT OF TEN OR
NOT.
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CAR
FIRE THAT WAS STARTED BY A OF A
MALFUNCTION OF A CALL OF A OF A
CAR IRONICALLY -- YOU LOOK AT
THE THE LAKE COUNTY FIRES OR
START BY PEOPLE WORKING ON ON
OFFENSE AND SOMEONE WORKING ON A
ON A HOT WATER HEATER.
THE LARGEST FIRE IN THE HISTORY
THE STATE THE RANCH IN THE RIVER
FIRE COMPLEX UP IN MENDOCINO IN
IN LAKE COUNTY LAST YEAR.
STARTED BY SOMEONE DOING RANCH
WORK.
SO THESE ARE THESE ARE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THESE PER
PREVENTION.
WE GOT OVER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE PEOPLE DIE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN IN THESE
FIRES WE DON'T NEED ONE MORE
PERSON TO DO THAT.
THE PREVENTION AND ESPECIALLY IN
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
BECAUSE IT ULTIMATELY WE DON'T
HELP PEOPLE PREVENT THESE FIRES
BY HARDENING THEIR HOMES IN
INCREASING DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT US ALL.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THAT OUR
INSURANCE MARKETS.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING INSURANCE AT A
AT A AT A REMARKABLE RATE WE'RE
BEING FORCED ON TO THE FAIR PLAN
WHICH WHICH MAKES THEIR
INSURANCE RATES GO UP VERY VERY
HIGH.
WHICH MEANS IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO SELL A HOUSE WHICH MEANS
IS DIFFICULT FOR SOMEONE TO BUY
THAT HOUSE BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY MORE FOR
INSURANCE.
THAT TRAIN IS COMING DOWN THE
TRACKS AND THAT IN AND OUT AND
AND WE'VE GOT TO DEAL WITH WITH
THAT AS WELL BUT I THINK WE DO
IT BY PREVENTING A RISK AND
PREVENTING -- THESE FIRES FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST PLACE TO
STABILIZE AT SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING IN ADDITION -- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE --
WE'RE NOT DONE FOLKS -- THIS IS
A HUGE STEP FORWARD.
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT IS A
HUGE STEP FORWARD AND I THINK WE
NEED TO DO MORE I LOOK FORWARD
TO DOING THAT I ASK YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD MISS
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF A
HIGH FIRE RISK AREA.
THIS ISSUE IS OF MAJOR CONCERN
TO MY DISTRICT.
I'VE HEARD A LOT OF JARGON IN
RECENT WEEKS ABOUT UTILITY
MARKETS GOVERNMENT COMMISSIONS
BOND HOLDERS RATE PAYERS AND
MORE.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT.
IS MAKING SURE WE TAKE CARE OF
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WHO DEPEND ON US TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON PEOPLE WHO RELY ON
US TO PROTECT THEM FROM
WILDFIRES.
THE PEOPLE WHO LOST EVERYTHING
IN OUR STATES RECENT FIRES.
AND WE TAKE CARE OF THE MALL
HERE. FOR CONSUMERS THEIR
CERTAINTY THAT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY WITHOUT PAYING
HIGHER RATES. FOR CALIFORNIANS
IN FIRE PRONE AREAS THERE ARE A
GROUNDBREAKING SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS TO PREVENT NEW
WILDFIRES FROM UTILITY EQUIPMENT.
AND FOR FIRE VICTIMS THERE IS A
GUARANTEE THAT THEY WILL BE MADE
WHOLE BEFORE P. JEANNIE WILL BE
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM.
SO LET'S FORGET ABOUT INVESTORS
AND COMMISSIONERS AND INSTEAD
FOCUS ON THE ONES WHO REALLY
MATTER.
THE ONES WHO ELECTED US WHO WE
ARE HERE TO LOOK OUT. FOR FOR
THEM I ORIGINAL VOTE THANK YOU.
NAME IS WALDER MISTER VOEPEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I SELDOM RISE WHICH IS PROBABLY
GREATLY APPRECIATED.
BUT THERE ARE SOME THINGS IN
THIS BILL I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THERE ARE THINGS IN THIS BILL
THAT NEED TO BE EITHER APPROVED
OR A FOLLOW ON BILL IN THE
FUTURE NEEDS TO MATERIALIZE.
WHAT WE'RE ADDRESSING HERE IS
THE IMMEDIATE PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE?
IN THE FUTURE THOUGH WE MUST
LOOK TO RISK MITIGATION.
IN INSURANCE TERM FOR TRYING TO
MITIGATE YOUR WRISTS.
AND ALSO WE NEED TO LOOK AT
LIMIT TEEN LAWSUITS RIGHT NOW IN
THE HIGH FIRE AREAS MANY PEOPLE
GO WITHOUT COVERAGE OR GO WITH
LESS COVERAGE.
BECAUSE OF AFFORDABILITY BY
DEFAULT THAT MAKES THE I. O. USE
THE INSURER OF CHOICE.
BECAUSE THESE LAWSUITS OF THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
SHOULD BE COVERED GREATLY BY THE
HOMEOWNERS THEMSELVES THROUGH A
PROPER INSURANCE PROGRAM.
OUR FARE PROGRAM FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT CAN'T QUALIFY.
FOR THE CORRECT INSURANCE NEEDS
TO BE REINFORCED [inaudible]
AND FINANCED AT A HIGHER LEVEL.
HOW WE DO THAT CAN BE WORKED OUT
DOWN THE ROAD?
AND THEN FINALLY.
AND I'M NOT SAYING THIS BRAGGING.
BUT OR SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC
OVER THE LAST ELEVEN YEARS HAS
DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
OF GRID MANAGEMENT.
AND PUTTING IN MONITORS
THROUGHOUT.
OUR AREA IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
ALMOST EVERY MOUNTAIN TOP HAS
SENSORS.
WE HAVE SATELLITE WE GO INTO
THEIR WEATHER CENTER AND THEY
CAN.
CONTROL THEIR DREAD DOWN TO VERY
SMALL AREAS THEY ALSO HAVE
BACKUP GENERATORS TO GO IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OFF THE GRID.
SO THAT SENIORS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT WE CARE ABOUT CAN HAVE THE
PROPER ENERGY SOURCES FOR THEIR
OXYGEN EXCEPT A SO.
A LOT CAN BE DONEBY P. G. AN E..
I AM ONLY MENTIONING S. D. G. AN
E. BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT JUST THE
THE MARK FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
PROBABLY FOR ALL THE WILD FIRE
AREAS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND I WOULD LIKE -- TO ALSO
[inaudible]
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT EVEN
THOUGH SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC IS
DONE A GREAT JOB.
THE MITIGATION STILL NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN THE RURAL AREAS OF MY
DISTRICT AND OUR REPRESENTATIVE
FROM ESCONDIDO -- MY DISTRICT
GOES FOR THE MEXICAN BORDER UP
TO BRAVE ASIDE AND WAY UP INTO --
THE HINTERLAND UP THERE.
I SELDOM GET THERE.
SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT THAT IS FORREST GUMP WOULD
SAY.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL
[inaudible]
MS RACE [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA ISN'T IN THE BUSINESS
OF BAILING OUT PRIVATE
CORPORATIONS.
BUT CALIFORNIA IS IN THE
BUSINESS OF PROTECTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AND RIGHT NOW CALIFORNIA FINDS
ITSELF IN THE POSITION REGARDING
UTILITIES.
AND THEIR STABILITY.
THAT REQUIRES ACTION NOW.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
I STRUGGLED WITH THIS I'VE HAD
SERIOUS DOUBTS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL NOT ONLY ABOUT THE
SUBSTANCE OF IT WHAT ABOUT THE
TIMELINE THAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
TO TAKE ACTION.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED SB NINE OH
ONE AFTER HOURS AND HOURS OF
HEARINGS.
AND STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS.
WE MADE HARD CHOICES BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE RESPONDED TO
THE CHALLENGE AND WORK TO
PROTECT VICTIMS REDUCE FUEL
LOADS.
AND PROVIDE A PATH FORWARD TO
THOSE UTILITIES THAT HAVE MADE
THE CHOICE TO ACT RESPONSIBLY.
NOW BEFORE AS WE ARE FACED WITH
A DIFFICULT CHOICE.
A CHOICE THAT FORCES US ALL TO
REMEMBER.
WHY WE WERE ELECTED WHY WE ARE
HERE IN THE FIRST PLACE?
I DID NOT COME TO SACRAMENTO TO
REPRESENT WALL STREET OR TO
RELIEVE THE ANXIETY OF PRIVATE
CORPORATIONS.
I WAS ELECTED.
I WAS SENT HERE TO REPRESENT MY
DISTRICT A TO REPRESENT
CALIFORNIANS [inaudible]
THIS PROPOSAL.
WITHOUT A DOUBT ALL FIRST
ABILITY TO UTILITIES.
IT OFFERS A PAL FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN GOOD ACTORS. TO ALLOW
THEM TO TAKE CARE OF THE VICTIMS
THE RATE PAYERS AND THE WORKERS.
BUT IT ALSO OFFERS A POUND FOR
THOSE.
WHO HAVE BEEN BAD ACTORS?
IT ALLOWS THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE.
ALLOWS THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET OUT OF BANKRUPTCY.
AND TO PROVE THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO PRIORITIZE SAFETY.
AND TO ENTER A FUND [inaudible]
THE PROVIDES. FOR THE STABILITY
THAT THEY NEED PROVIDES A
PROTECTION FOR THEIR WORKERS.
FOR THE RATE PAYERS.
AND FOR THE VICTIMS.
IN THE END.
OUR JOB IS TO STABILIZE
CALIFORNIA.
AFTER MANY DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WITH THE
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
TODAY.
I BELIEVE THAT AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
CREATES THE CONDITIONS AND THE
STANDARDS. TO STABILIZE
CALIFORNIA.
AND TO CHANGE THE BEHAVIOR OF
PGA ANY.
THAT IS WHY IN SPITE OF MY
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL.
I BELIEVE THAT FAILING TO ACT
TODAY MAY BE WORSE THAN THE
STATUS QUO.
AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR I BELIEVE IS A
BEGINNING.
AND THAT IT WILL PROTECT OUR
RATE PAYERS IT WILL PROTECT OUR
FIRE VICTIMS.
IT'LL PROTECT OUR WORKERS.
AND THAT IS THE REASON.
WHY I WAS ELECTED TO BE HERE AND
THAT IS THE REASON I AM ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION TODAY?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDRESS MR BLOOM.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO JOIN IN THE CHORUS OF THOSE
WHO ARE.
SUPPORTING THIS IN AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
OF WHEN I WAS A A YOUNG CHILD
GROWING UP NOT FAR FROM -- THE
WHERE THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
LIVES -- ONE OF MY EARLIEST
RECOLLECTIONS -- IS WATCHING A
FIRE -- CLIMB UP THROUGH THE SAN
GABRIEL MOUNTAINS TO THE BASE OF
THE SAN GABRIEL MOUNTAINS AND TO
FURTHER FURTHER UP VERY VERY
RAPIDLY TOWARDS MOUNT WILSON
THAT WAS A LARGE FIRE THERE AND
BUT IT STUCK IN MY MIND AND WHO
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT YEARS
LATER -- I WOULD BE EXPERIENCING
FIRE AFTER FIRE AFTER FIRE AND
THAT'S SO -- THE REMARKABLE
THING THAT WE FACE TODAY IT'S
NOT THAT FIRE EXISTS BUT IT'S
THE INTENSITY AND THE FREQUENCY
WITH WHICH THEY ARE OCCURRING.
I'M IT IS.
PRETTY INCREDIBLE TO TO WATCH
THIS DEBATE AND SEE HOW MANY
MEMBERS FROM AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GETTING UP AND
SAYING.
THERE WAS A FIRE IN MY DISTRICT
AND MY DISTRICT WAS AFFECTED AND
IN THE FOLLOWING WAY AND THAT'S
WHAT.
A FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN MEANT
WHEN HE SAID THAT THIS IS THE
NEW NORMAL -- THAT WAS ONE OF
THOSE STATEMENTS THAT I THINK
REALLY GALVANIZED US AND BEGAN.
MOVING US FORWARD TOWARDS WHERE
WE ARE TODAY BUT THIS IS A
CONTINUING.
OF WHAT WE DO TODAY IS ONLY PART
OF THE SOLUTION -- WE NEED -- TO
NOT ONLY CONTINUE LEGISLATING ON
THIS ISSUE BUT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE BUDGETING AROUND FIRE
AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE AROUND
ADDRESSING.
THE THE URBAN INTERFACE THE
MANAGEMENT OF OUR FOR US --
THERE ARE SO MANY SO MANY THINGS --
MY DISTRICTS MOST RECENT
EXPERIENCE WITH WITH FIRE AFTER
SEEING IT IN BEL AIR IN
BRENTWOOD -- IN PACIFIC
PALISADES OF MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
FIRES IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS THE MOST RECENT FAR
WAS THE WILL THE FIRE -- WHICH
WAS A DEVASTATING FIRE -- TOOK
OUT HUNDREDS OF HOMES -- AND WE
LOST TWO LIVES IN IN THE WORLD
THE FIRE.
I IT IT IS.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE I AND IN THE
HOPES THAT WE WILL NOT SEE THAT
AGAIN BUT IN THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
WE PROBABLY WILL -- THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
MR LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE EFFORT THAT HAS PUT
INTO THIS BILL.
BUT IT'S BEEN PUT INTO THIS BILL
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BY.
MY FELLOW LAWMAKERS BY THE STAFF
AND MANY OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ACHIEVE LAUDABLE.
GOALS HOWEVER.
CONSIDERABLE EFFORT AND GOOD
INTENTIONS DO NOT NECESSARILY
LEAD. TO SOUND POLICY WHEN A
PRINCIPAL BENEFICIARY OF THAT
POLICY HAS AN EGREGIOUSLY BAD
RECORD ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND CORPORATE STORAGE SHED.
YESTERDAY THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL PUBLISHED A REMINDER TO
ALL OF US.
OF P. GENIES LET ME OF NEGLECT
OF ITS OBLIGATIONS TO MAINTAIN.
ITS INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE ARTICLE DETAILED P. GENIES
WILLFUL NEGLECT OF TRANSMISSION
LINE EQUIPMENT THAT IGNITED THE
CAMPFIRE LAST NOVEMBER.
AND HOW THERE ARE MANY OTHER
LINES INCLUDING THE IGNACIO MARE
ISLAND LINE.
THAT EXTENDS THROUGH MARIN
COUNTY.
THAT IS PART OF THE SAME
CARRABELLE THE LOAN A SYSTEM
WITH POWER SPEAKING BACK.
TO NINETEEN TWENTY ONE THAT ARE
IN SERIOUS NEED OF REPAIR.
AND PGA ANY HAS KNOWN ABOUT IT.
BUT THOSE REPAIRS HAVE BEEN
POSTPONED TIME AND AGAIN.
IN FACT P. GINNY PERK FIRST
PROPOSED WORK ON THE MARIN LINE
AN EXTRAORDINARILY FIRE PRONE
REGION OF THE COUNTY IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND THIS WORK
HAS YET TO COMMENCE.
THESE TOWERS ARE AS OLD AS
NINETY EIGHT YEARS SIMILAR TO
THE TOWER THAT FAILED.
IN THE CAMP FIRE RESULTING.
IN EIGHTY FIVE DEATHS.
THEY KNEW EACH IN A NEW AND THEY
DID NOTHING.
THEFAILURE OF THESE LINES IS
NOT A POTENTIAL CATASTROPHE
WAITING TO HAPPEN IT IS A
CATASTROPHE THAT WILL HAPPEN.
AGING IS RECORD OF NEGLECT
PROVES THIS OUT.
YOU'D THINK AFTER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PGA ANY.
WOULD HAVE WOKEN UP TO THE
DANGER AND SUBSTANTIATED FEARS.
THAT FUTURE FIRES CAUSED BY
NEGLECT COULD COST THE LIVES.
OF MANY MORE.
HOW COULD THEY NOT?
YOU'D THINK THAT AFTER THE
NIGHTMARE EXPLOSION THAT KILLED
EIGHT PEOPLE IN SAN BRUNO IN.
TWENTY TEN BUT IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE EVENT THAT HIGHLIGHTED.
THE NEED FOR A NEW FOUND RESPECT
FOR SAFETY FOR UNDERGROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BY P. JEANNIE HOWEVER EARLIER
THIS YEAR.
MY ATTENTION WAS DRAWN TO A P.
YOU SEE REPORT ON P. GENIES
MALFEASANCE REGARDING THE
LOCATION OF ITS SUBSURFACE
PIPELINES FOR EXCAVATION CRUZ.
TO OPERATE SAFELY.
AT CONSTRUCTION SITES FORMER PC
COMMISSIONER CATHERINE SAND OF
ALL CALL THE REPORT'S FINDINGS.
DISCUSS DEAN AND DEEPLY
APPALLING. EIGHT PEOPLE DIED IN
THAT EXPLOSION BACK IN SAN BRUNO
AND THEY STILL DIDN'T FIX.
THEIR PROBLEMS.
WHAT PROMPTED ME TO INTRODUCE AB
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX WITH WHICH THIS?
HOUSE PASSED THIS YEAR TO
BOLSTER THE PIPELINE LOCATION OF
OCCASION PROCESS WE SHOULD DO
THE SAME. TO BOLSTER
TRANSMISSION LINE SAFETY.
WE SHOULD DO THE SAME MEMBERS I
HOPE THE DISGRACEFUL PAST A
PUBLIC SAFETY NEGLECT.
AND THE MURDER OF INNOCENT LIVES
IS NOT A PROLOGUE TO FURTHER P.
GINNY RELATED DEVASTATION.
IT IS HARD NOT TO SEE THIS BILL
AS SOMETHING.
OF A REWARD FOR MONSTROUS
BEHAVIOR.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE THE WORK THEY
SHOULD NOT BE REWARDED.
OUR EFFORTS SHOULD MAKE PUBLIC
SAFETY PARAMOUNT.
IF WE ARE TO ENTRUST THIS BILL
WITH BEING A CORNERSTONE.
OF TRUE CHANGE FOR THE BETTER.
LET IT ABSOLUTELY BE THE LAST
TIME YOU DO.
IF THAT CHANGE DOES NOT OCCUR I
CERTAINLY WILL NOT MY VOTE IS
NOW.
THANK YOU MISS LIVING IS
PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY FOR THE REPAIRS OF
MY DISTRICT FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
I REPRESENT AND FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WHO WE ALL REPRESENT AS MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOTED?
THIS BILL IS NOT PERFECT AND
THIS CONVERSATION IS NOT OVER.
BUT I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT THE
COST OF INACTION TODAY IS SIMPLY
TOO HIGH AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
WE MUST ACT.
WE MUST ACT NOW NOT TO STABILIZE
THE UTILITY MARKETS BUT TO
STABILIZE CALIFORNIA.
AND TO PROTECT OUR WITH RATE
PAYERS AND YES TO STABILIZE THE
FUNDAMENTAL FINANCIAL MARKETS OF
OUR STATE.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE MUST ALSO
ENSURE THAT WE DO A BETTER JOB
OF ALIGNING THE INCENTIVES FOR
OUR INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES SO
THAT THEY IN PARTICULAR.
LEE P. JEANNIE THEY ARE
INCENTIVIZED TO ACT PRUDENTLY TO
ACT RESPONSIBLY ANDTO MAKE
BUSINESS DECISIONS THE PROTECT
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS WE
MUST ALSO.
AS THIS BODY.
DO A BETTER JOB IN OUR ROLE AS
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT FOR THESE
UTILITIES NOW AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SO.
I JOIN TODAY IN THE CHORUS OF
SUPPORT FOR AT TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN WE COME BACK.
THE MIDDLE OF AUGUST WE CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION AND WE
CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE CONTINUE TO
DO A BETTER JOB. FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISS PETRIE-NORRIS
MISTER MURATSUCHI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK.
EVERYONE THIS WORKED HARD ON
THIS BILL I SPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR. FOR LEADING
THIS EFFORT. TO PUT TO THE
DETAILS OF WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON
IN FRONT OF US HERE TODAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD.
IN THIS BILL THERE THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF THOUGHT A LOT OF SMART
PEOPLE THAT WORKED REALLY HARD.
TO PUT TOGETHER THIS BILL.
THE QUESTION THAT REMAINS IN MY
MIND IS WHETHER.
WE COULD HAVE DONE BETTER.
IF WE HAD MORE THAN TWO WEEKS
DID THE PAID THE DETAILS.
OF THIS BILL [inaudible]
LAST YEAR.
WE WERE TOLD THAT IF WE DIDN'T
PASS -- SB NINE A ONE BY
IMMINENT DEADLINE.
THAT SHE KNEW WAS GONNA GO
BANKRUPT.
AND SO WE JUMPED AND WE PASSED
SB NINE A ONE THEN FOR IT THEN
PREVENT.
ANY DIFFERENT GOING INTO
BANKRUPTCY.
BUT WE DID OUR BEST [inaudible]
NOW.
WE'RE BEING ASKED. TO PASS THIS
BILL.
AND IF WE DON'T PASS IT
ACCORDING.
TO THE GOVERNOR IF WE DON'T PASS
IT BY JULY TWELFTH.
THEN.
EDISON IS GOING TO BE DOWNGRADED
TO JUNK BOND STATUS AND THEY MAY
FACE BANKRUPTCY.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SEE THAT PATTERN [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
SO THAT.
IT INFORMS US.
AS WE GO FORWARD WITH ALL THE
WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT GOING
TO BE.
THE END.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN.
THAT I SHARE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS IS THE WEAKENING OF
THE PROJECT MANAGER STANDARD.
THIS ONLY PROTECTS RATE PAYERS.
AND I CONFIRM THIS DURING OUR
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
HEARING YESTERDAY THIS ONLY
[inaudible]
CAPS THE INCREASED COSTS FOR
RATEPAYERS AS LONG AS THE FUN
LAUGHS.
WELL FOLKS.
AS OUR CHAIRMAN.
OF THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE STRONGER OFTEN IS
PRESENTATION OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
TALK ABOUT. TEN OF THE WORST
WILDFIRES IN THE HISTORY OF THE
SANTA CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN JUST
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
AND IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HERE AND NOW.
AND IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET WORSE
AND SO IT.
WE FACED A PROPERTY DAMAGE
LIABILITY JUSTIN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF
OVER TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS.
AND NOW THE PROJECTION IS AT
THIS FORTY BILLION DOLLAR FUND
IS GOING WAS IS GOING TO LAST US
FOR TEN YEARS.
DO THE MATH.
MY CONCERN IS THAT WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO PACKAGE TOGETHER
[inaudible]
AND ADDRESS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE INVOLVED IN
THIS AND THIS [inaudible]
CRISIS HERE.
I CAN SHARE.
MY CONCERN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD ABOUT.
HOW THE INSURANCE COMPANIES WERE
WERE ASKING RATE PAYERS TO PAY
AND WE'RE ASKING UTILITIES TO
PAN WHERE THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES?
THEY'RE NOT PART OF THIS DEAL.
INSURANCE COMPANIES.
NEED TO BE STEPPING UP. TO
ADDRESS.
THIS COST CRISIS THAT WE'RE
FACING.
AND WE ALSO HAVE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE OF STRICT LIABILITY.
I KNOW THAT THAT'S ON POPULAR
ESPECIALLY FOR MEMBERS THAT
REPRESENT.
PAGE YOU NEED JURISDICTIONS.
BUT IT I I THINK.
THERE NEEDS TO BE GROWING
AWARENESS THAT RATE PAIR
ADVOCATES LIKE TURN SUPPORT.
INVERSE CONDEMNATION REFORM.
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS LIKE THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL SUPPORT INVERSE
CONDEMNATION REFORM [inaudible]
WE CAN'T.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE WEAKENED
PRUDENT MENACED STANDARD THAT'S
ONLY GOING TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THE UTILITIES TO PASS WHAT FAR
COST ALONG TO RATE PAYERS.
WE CAN'T KEEP ASKING RATE PAYERS
TO BEAR THE EVER INCREASING
COSTS OF WILDFIRES.
SO I JUST WANT [inaudible]
TO EMPHASIZE.
HOWEVER THE VOTE TURNS OUT TODAY.
THAT THIS BILL IS JUST BUYING
TIME.
I CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO GET
WORSE.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF UNFINISHED
WORK TO DO.
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO US SUPPORT.
IN CONCURRENCE WITH THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
MONEY JUST MAKE A COUPLE OF
SIGNIFICANT POINTS HERE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THIS IS WELL BALANCED.
THE RATE PAYERS PAY NO MORE IN
FEES OR IN RATE INCREASES THEN
THEY PRESENTLY DO THIS DOES NOT
TOUCH.
RATE INCREASES NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER TWO IT IT PROVIDES AN
UNPRECEDENTED. TEN ALMOST ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
SHAREHOLDERS OF THE UTILITIES.
AND I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THAT THE SHAREHOLDERS.
ARE NOT JOSH STE.
BACK IN WALL STREET.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS IN A
FOR A ONCE AND IN THEIR
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS.
ARE EXPOSED.
TO UTILITY INVESTMENTS.
WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF A SECOND
OR A THIRD.
MAJOR UTILITY BEING UNDER THE
KIND OF STRESS.
OF THAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING. TO
DEAL WITH HERE PRESENTLY.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS A
CENTRAL. FOR US TO TAKE THIS
STEP.
BUT OTHER MEMBERS HERE TAKE
SAYING ADDITIONAL STEPS AS WELL.
AND THAT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT -- BUT SERVED ON THE
UTILITY AND ENERGY. FOR FIVE AND
A HALF YEARS THIS IS CLOSE TO ME.
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT AND I
COMMEND OUR CHAIR FOR THE WORK
AND THAT HE'S DONE.
ON THIS.
BUT I COME AT THIS ALSO.
AS SOMEONE.
WHO REALLY BELIEVES THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
HAS TO START GETTING.
THE KINDS OF RESOURCES AND THE
KINDS OF EFFORTS IN C. INTO IT
THAT WE GET THESE FIRES PUT OUT
EARLY AND THAT THEY DO NOT
EXPLODE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SEE ONE THIRTIES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE COMING ON
LINE WITH TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
RETARDANTS.
SUBSTANTIALLY -- IN THE FUTURE
WE ARE SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING PRE
POSITIONING.
ALL ON A REGULAR BASIS OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS THE THE THE TRUCKS
ND ALL OF THAT SO THAT WHEN WE
SEE IT SPARK WE CAN GET
RESOURCES TO IT.
QUICKLY.
I HAVEN'T IN THIS.
ALMOST SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE
I HAVE NOT SEEN A MORE FOCUSED.
SERIOUS CONCERN ON WHAT DO WE DO
NOW.
THIS IS A STEPPING POINT FOR
STABILITY.
INSTABILITY COULD VERY WELL MEAN.
BANKRUPTCY FOR ALL OF THESE
UTILITIES.
AND THAT WOULD BE.
A TERRIBLE OCCURRENCE. FOR
RELIABILITY FOR RATES -- AND FOR
THE FUNDAMENTAL DELIVERY OF
ELECTRICITY.
MEMBERS WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY ON THE PLANET.
WE ARE ALMOST TWENTY YEARS INTO
THE A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY M..
DUST CALIFORNIA ELECTRICITY GRID
IS.
SOMEWHAT DISINTEGRATING IN FRONT
OF OUR EYES.
AND WE HAVE SEEN RELIABILITY
ISSUES AND WE HAVE SEEN COST
ISSUES.
THAT HAVE DRIVEN SOME PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA SAY WE CAN'T AFFORD.
THIS KIND OF EXPENSE.
IT ONLY GETS WORSE IF THE GRID
CONTINUES. TO DE TO TO TO BE. TO
START FALLING APART AND I KNOW
THIS SOUNDS A BIT [inaudible]
DRACONIAN.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A GRADE ISSUE.
AND WE HAVE A STABILITY ISSUE.
AND WE HAVE A FINANCE ISSUE.
AND DOING NOTHING.
IS A CERTAINTY THAT WE WILL JUST
SEE THE PROBLEMS IN THE PGA ANY
SERVICE AREA.
IN A BUNCH OF OTHER AREAS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN I WANT TO A CLOSE WITH
A UP A PERSONAL [inaudible]
PLAY.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ALSO
STANDING UP AND SAYING WE GOT TO
DO A WHOLE WHOLE LOT MORE.
IN MANAGING OUR FOREST AND
GETTING THESE DEAD TREES OUT WE
HAVE FUEL.
ARE THAT ISN'T.
THE UTILITIES BALK LYING ALL
OVER OUR FORESTS AND WE'VE GOT
TO GET THOSE THAT MATERIAL OUT.
AND WE'VE GOT TO GET OUR FORESTS
MANAGED SO THAT THEY DO NOT
EXPLODE.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
PHOTOGRAPHS FOR EXAMPLE OF OUR
FORESTS FIFTY YEARS AGO THEY HAD
SOMETHING LIKE A HUNDRED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TREES. TO THE
ACRE WE NOW HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
FIVE HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED TREES
TO THE THEIR TENDER BOXES WERE
READY TO EXPLODE.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO FIGHT
FIRES IN A MUCH.
BIGGER MORE BROADER MORE ROBUST
WAY WE'VE GOT TO MANAGE OUR
FORESTS.
AND THEN I'M JUST GOING TO SAY
THIS I HAVE MY DAUGHTER MY SON
IN LAW TO OF OUR FOUR GRAND KIDS
THEY LIVE AT THREE THOUSAND FEET
UP IN THE FOREST AREA OUT OF OUT
OF BASS LAKE.
AREA [inaudible]
THEY'RE FRIGHTENED.
THEY'RE AFRAID THEY HAVE EXIT
PLANS AND THEY LIVE IN A PLACE
WHERE THEY COULD BE NEXT.
DOING WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW AND
IN THE FUTURE.
I HOPE TO GOD WILL HELP SAVE NOT
ONLY MY LOVED ONES.
BUT YOUR LOVED ONES AS WELL SO I
URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON DOCTOR
QUIRK.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR ME TO ASK.
YES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TEN FIFTY FOUR OTHER NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED BY.
MY COLLEAGUES THAT I HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER.
FIRST OF ALL WHY DID SB NINE A
ONE FAIL.
IT'S BECAUSE WE GAVE THE P. YOU
SEE THE AUTHORITY.
AND THE PRESIDENT PICKER THE P.
YOU SEE SAID -- RE READ NINE NO
ONE WE DIDN'T THINK IT REQUIRED
US TO ACT.
THAT CAUSED A DISASTER THIS BILL
DOES NOT DEPEND UPON THE P. YOU
SEE.
AND IN FACT. ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAS SUGGESTED THAT WE
NEED TO GET P. G. NEED TO REPAIR
THEIR LINES.
AND FRANKLY IF WE HAD TO DEPEND
UPON THE P. YOU SEE IS NON.
AS NON WORKING AS IT IS NOW I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE DO THAT THAT'S
WHY WE'RE SETTING UP A SEPARATE
SAFETY -- DEPARTMENT WHICH WILL
EVENTUALLY.
GO OUT OF THE P. YOU SEE OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS TO ENFORCE
THAT SAFETY.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS FAR
SUPERIOR TO NINE A ONE BECAUSE
WE WE ARE BYPASSING THE P. YOU
SEE -- AND I BELIEVE THIS WILL
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET.
P. JEANNIE AND THE OTHER
UTILITIES TO UPGRADE THEIR LINES.
FINALLY THERE'S A QUESTION OF
THE FUN DURABILITY.
AND TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A LOT GIVEN
WHAT'S HAPPENED BUT IT IS AND
HERE'S WHY.
IS BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING
PROACTIVE STEPS NOW.
THAT THE UTILITIES ARE TURNING
OFF THEIR WIRES WHEN WE GET HI
FIRE.
OFF -- DAYS HIGH FIRE PROPENSITY
DAYS WHEN EARLIER THIS YEAR
THERE WAS A DRY DAY WITH HIGH
WINDS AND HIGH TEMPERATURES THE
LINES WERE TURNED OFF.
FURTHER WE'RE WORKING ON
MANAGING OUR FORESTS AND TAKING
MANY OTHER PROACTIVE STEPS
[inaudible]
THIS -- FUND WAS LOOKED AT BUY.
A CONSULTING GROUP. TO SAY WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE TO STABILIZE THESE
UTILITIES WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO
HELP OUT THE VICTIMS THIS IS A
NUMBER THEY CAME UP WITH.
NOT LOOKING AT WHAT WE'VE DONE
BUT WHAT WE WILL DO.
I URGE EVERYONE TO SUPPORT AB
TEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK THAT PURPOSE CUNNINGHAM.
YOUR RECORDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND P. GENIES
CONDUCT WE ALL TRUSTED THEM FOR
DECADES.
WE TRUSTED THEY WOULD INVEST IN
SAFETY AND HARDEN THE GRADE AND
THEY LET US DOWN.
WE CAN'T CHANGE THAT WE CAN ONLY
DEAL.
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND DEAL WITH
THE FUTURE.
AND IF YOU DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN AGAIN THEN I SUGGEST YOU
NEED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
BECAUSE IT FORCES THEM IF FORCES
ALL THE UTILITIES TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS TO HARDEN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO UPGRADE
THE GRID AND WHAT LET'S PUT A
HUMAN FACE FOR SECOND ON
BANKRUPTCY.
IT HAS A TOLL IT MEANS DELAYED
COMPENSATION FOR FIRE VICTIMS.
IT MEANS WORKERS RUN CERTAIN
ABOUT THEIR PAYCHECKS.
IT MEANS THAT PEOPLE SUFFER IT
MEANS.
THAT DOWNSTREAM COMPANIES ARE AT
RISK OF BANKRUPTCY IN MY
DISTRICT THERE'S THE TOPAZ
VALLEY SOLAR POWER PLANT.
THAT FACILITY AND THE OWNERS
THAT FACILITY THE SECOND P.
JEANNIE WENT BANKRUPT.
THE SECOND THEY WENT BANKRUPT
THE OWNERS OF THAT FACILITY.
THEY WERE DOWNGRADED TO JUNK
BOND STATUS.
BECAUSE OF P. GENIES BANKRUPTCY.
WE CANNOT SITE SOLAR POWER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PRESENTLY.
THAT'S A PROBLEM FOLKS.
WE'VE ENACTED SOME VERY VERY
AMBITIOUS CLEAN ENERGY GOALS IN
THE STATE AND TO GET TO EIGHT TO
BE AND REACH THOSE GOALS.
WE NEED INDUSTRIAL SCALE SOLAR
WE NEED OFFSHORE WIND WE NEED ON
SHORE WHEN WE NEED RENEWABLE
POWER.
AND WHEN YOU'VE GOT A BANKRUPT
UTILITY.
YOU HAVE NOBODY TO BUY THAT
ENERGY AND DISTRIBUTED.
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
SO LET'S CONSIDER THE HUMAN TOLL
[inaudible]
I BELIEVE.
THE RISK TO THE OTHER UTILITIES
ISRAEL.
I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION.
THIS BILL FOR THE FIRST TIME I
SAY THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO DID NOT
VOTE FOR NINE A ONE I VOTED NO.
AND IF YOU TOLD ME THAT.
THIS BODY WOULD COME UP WITH A
PLAN THAT WOULD PROTECT REPAIRS
[inaudible]
WOULD GET.
COMPENSATION MORE QUICKLY TO
FIRE VICTIMS.
WOULD FORCE THE UTILITIES TO
INVEST IN HARDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WOULD DO ALL THAT.
AND STABILIZE THE ENERGY MARKETS
SO WE CAN SAID ABOUT.
PROVIDING POWER CHEAP CLEAN AND
SAFE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD HAVE
BELIEVED YOU.
BUT THEY DID IT.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THERE WAS CUNNINGHAM AND MISTER
MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER -- AS
A A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR OF AB AT
TEN FIFTY FOUR I'M I'M OBVIOUSLY --
IN SUPPORT OF IT.
AND AS SOMEBODY WHO'S NOW SERVED
IN THIS BODY GOING ON MY FIFTH
YEAR WHICH SEEMS LIKE I'VE BEEN
HERE A LOT LONGER THAN FIVE
YEARS -- I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THIS IS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WE CAN ALL.
BE PROUD OF IT IS NOT PERFECT I
THINK IT'S ALL BEEN SAID IN FACT
I DON'T WANT TO MAKE ANY MORE
ARGUMENTS ON THE MERITS OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE I THINK THOSE
ARGUMENTS HAVE ALL BEEN SAID --
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN OF UTILITIES SO OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA FOR HIS
STEADY HAND ON HIS SHARP MIND IN
HIS FINE WORK AS HIS LEAD.
THEY'RE ALL OF THIS I ALSO WANT
TO PRAISE NOW COLLEAGUE FROM --
FROM INGLEWOOD WHO IS DONE TO
COME A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
ON THIS AS WELL AND I ALSO WANT
TO PRAISE -- THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS TEAM FOR THE SERIOUSNESS
THAT HE'S PUT IN A TO THIS
MEASURE.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING NEW.
THIS IS NOT ON THE FAST TRACK AS
IT'S BEEN SAID.
I WANNA REMIND SOME OF YOU THAT
IT WAS JANUARY OF LAST YEAR THAT
MANY OF US BEGAN WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES IN TWO DIFFERENT.
WORKING GROUPS ONE LED BY.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM INGLEWOOD
ANOTHER ONE LED BY THE CHAIRMAN
OF UTILITIES WE SPENT HOURS AND
HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS
STUDYING THIS ISSUE AND THEN WE
ENDED UP ON THE NIGHT A ONE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
AND ENDED UP SPENDING HOURS AND
HOURS AND HOURS WORKING ON THIS
ISSUES THEN WE KNEW AT THE TIME
WHEN THE NOT A ONE OF COMMITTEE
REPORT WAS DONE THAT IT WASN'T
FINISHED IN THAT THERE WAS MORE
WORK THAT HAD TO BE DONE.
THIS YEAR.
WE HAD THAT WITH THE NEW
GOVERNOR AND THE NEW GOVERNOR
WANT TO WORK RIGHT AWAY TO START
TACKLING THIS ISSUES.
AND WE CAN REMEMBER THAT IN
APRIL HE HAD HIS STRIKE FORCE
REPORT THAT WAS THAT WAS PUT OUT.
AND THEN WE ASK THEN I DON'T
COMMISSION TO FINISH THEIR WORK
UP AND THEY DID AND THEY PUT A
VERY COMPLETE.
WORK PRODUCT TOGETHER THEY ENDED
UP.
THE LA -- ENDED UP PUTTING A
WORK PRODUCT OUT OUT AS WELL IN
ALL OF THESE ISSUES THAT ARE IN
THIS BILL WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT.
THIS BILL IS NOT PERFECT BUT IS
THE BEST THAT WE ALL COULD COME
UP WITH THIS IS A WORK.
OF OF COMPROMISE IS A WORK OF
COLLABORATION IT WAS REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WORKING TOGETHER.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL
BE PROUD OF I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MESS MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I WILL I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS OF THIS LEGISLATION --
WHO HAVE LED SOME VERY
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSIONS IN THIS
LEGISLATURE?
AT THROUGHOUT THIS YOU'RE GOING
TO LAST YEAR.
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
DO.
SOME OF WHICH ARE IN THIS BILL.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
I'M PRETTY TORN UP.
BY THIS LEGISLATION I'VE BEEN
STEWING ABOUT IT ALL WEEK.
AFTER ALL OF MY COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN THROUGH OVER THESE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS [inaudible]
HOMES.
BUSINESSES LOST WHOLE
COMMUNITIES WIPED OUT. EIGHTY
FIVE PEOPLE KILLED.
WE'RE PRETTY TORN UP ABOUT
[inaudible]
THIS BILL.
NGUYEN P. JEANNIE DECIDED TO
DECLARE BANKRUPTCY IN JANUARY IT
WAS A PUNCH IN OUR GUT.
RATHER THAN ALLOW THE
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS TO PROCEED.
AND TO DECIDE WHAT THEIR ACTUAL
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS WERE THEY
DECIDED TO DECLARE BANKRUPTCY.
NOT OUR CHOICE LIKE THE DECISION
TO DELAY MAINTENANCE.
ONLINE'S WAS NOT OUR CHOICE.
JUST LIKE THE DECISION TO PAY
DIVIDENDS TO SHAREHOLDERS.
AND BONUSES TO EXECUTIVES TO THE
VERY EXECUTIVES WHO MADE THESE
TRADE OFFS.
WAS NOT OUR DECISION.
WE NEW BANKRUPTCY.
WHAT IT MEANT FOR US?
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE CLAIMS ON
THIS COMPANY WOULD BE PENNIES ON
THE DOLLAR.
THAT'S WHAT WE KNEW.
AND WE HAVE COME TO THE VERY
HARD REALIZATION THAT THE ONLY
THING WORSE THAN AN INEPT
UTILITY.
IS A BANKRUPT.
ONE WHAT DECISIONS AS MY
COMMUNITY GET TO MAKE.
HOW TO REBUILD FROM THE ASHES?
WILL BE AFFORDABLE WOULD BE ABLE
TO GET INSURANCE.
HOW DO WE FIX CONTAMINATED WATER?
WHERE DO WE GO UNTIL THEN HOW DO
WE PREPARE?
REPAIR DAMAGED INFRASTRUCTURE.
THOSE ARE THE DECISIONS THAT MY
TO MY COMMUNITY GETS TO MAKE.
HOW DO YOU PREPARE FOR POWER
SHUT OFFS?
THESE ARE ALL TOUGH DECISIONS
WITH NO EASY ANSWERS.
SO WHAT DO I DO WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IT'S ANOTHER TOUGH
DECISION FOR ME.
A HOBSON'S CHOICE DO I DEAL WITH
THE DEVIL THAT I KNOW. FOR THE
DEVIL THAT I DON'T.
IF WE LET IT ALL CRASH DOWN IT
WOULD BE JUST DESSERTS. FOR A
COMPANY THAT HAS BEEN AS NEGLECT
NEGLIGENT AS THIS.
ONE BUT WOULD IT BE FAIR FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE.
AND I'LL USE THAT SERVE THEM. TO
SEE THEIR CREDIT DOWNGRADED IT
TO SEE MORE BANKRUPTCIES.
WHAT ABOUT THE WORKERS?
THE LINEMEN IN THE FRONTLINE
WORKERS.
THEY LIVE IN MY DISTRICT AND
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING TIRE IS
TIRELESSLY TO RESTORE POWER AND
TO KEEP THE POWER ON THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT GO OUT.
IN THESE DISASTERS IN THE STORMS.
MAKE SURE IT'S ON SHOULD THEY
PAY THE PRICE FOR THE BAD
DECISIONS OF HIGHER UPS. FOR P.
JEANNIE MAYBE WE SHOULD SEE
WHAT'S ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS
BANKRUPTCY.
MAYBE THEIR ASSETS SHOULD BE
SOLD. TO SOMEONE MORE
RESPONSIBLE AND WHO WOULD
OPERATE MORE EFFICIENTLY MAYBE A
BREAK UP WOULD BE BETTER.
BUT I KNOW THAT MANY WHO ARE
ROOTING FOR THIS BILL TO FAIL.
WANT TO SEE THE GOVERNMENT TAKE
OVER P. JEANNIE.
AND IF THERE'S ONE THING I KNOW
IF THERE'S ANYTHING WORSE THAN
BIG GOVERNMENT ARE SORRY BIG
BUSINESS.
IS BIG GOVERNMENT.
IN FACT GOVERNMENT IS THE REASON
THAT WE IS P. JEANNIE CUSTOMERS
PAY THE HIGHEST BILLS.
IN THE NATION.
AND ALL THE WHILE WILD FIRE
VICTIMS WOULD MOST ASSUREDLY
MISS OUT.
AND THAT'S THE BEST NEWS IT'S IN
THIS BILL.
IT PROBABLY MOST EFFECTIVELY
LEVERAGES THIS COMPANY TO DO
RIGHT BY THE WILD FIRE VICTIMS.
IF THEY WANT THE BENEFITS OF
THIS INSURANCE FUND THEY HAVE TO
PAY THE VICTIMS AND COME OUT OF
BANKRUPTCY.
BY NEXT YEAR NO DRAGGING THEM
ALONG FOR THE RIDE.
BUT THERE'S NO GUARANTEE IN THIS
BILL THAT THE I. O. USE IN THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS WILL PAY INTO THAT
FUND.
ONLY IF THEY ELECT.
TO AND OF COURSE IT'S NOT LOST
ON ANY OF US THAT P. JEANNIE
RIGHT NOW IS ASKING FOR A RATE
INCREASE.
FROM OUR RATE PAYERS.
P. JEANNIE ALSO PROMISES THAT
SHAREHOLDERS WILL PICK UP.
THE COST OF PAIN VICTIMS.
THERE DEBT HOLDERS WOULD RATHER
DO IT THEMSELVES IN FACT THERE
WERE THERE READY TO PUT THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN. TO DO IT
THEMSELVES.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME.
THAT I'VE EVER SEEN SHAREHOLDER
GROUPS AT PGA ANY FIGHT OVER WHO
SHOULD PAY.
INSTEAD OF PASSING THE BUCK TO
US PLEASE INCLUDE AS GALLAGHER.
WELL IF THEY EACH WANNA PAY.
MAYBE BOTH OF THEM SHOULD PAY SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO PAY
ANYMORE.
I'M SORRY IF YOU WOULD AND TOLD
HIM MISTER SPEAKER BUT IF WE IF
ALL WE DO TODAY IS PASS THIS
BILL.
WE WILL HAVE FAILED.
WE MAY SAY THE DAY.
FOR TODAY.
BUT IT WILL BE A VICTORY THAT AS
A PYRRHIC.
ONE IF WE DON'T DO THE THINGS
THAT WE ALL KNOW WE NEED TO DO
AND SOME OF YOU ALLUDED TO THEM.
IF WE DON'T DRASTICALLY REFORM
THE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF
THESE I'LL USE THE P. YOU SEE IS
NOT GETTING IT DONE FOLKS.
IF WE DON'T DEAL WITH THE
UNDERLYING FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE OF
FUELS.
WE CAN'T CONTROL WHEN OR WHERE
THE WIND BLOWS.
BUT WE MOST ASSUREDLY CAN
CONTROL THE FUEL ON OUR FORCES
AND BRUSH LANDS HOW ABOUT FULLY
FUNDING OR FIRE SAFE COUNCILS.
WHO ARE DOING GOD'S WORK IN
HELPING PROTECT THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT HELP PROTECT?
MY COMMUNITY DURING THE CAMPFIRE
MR GALLAGHER AND ASK YOU
CONCLUDE PLEASE HARDEN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND MAKE THEM MORE
RESILIENT.
WE NEED RATE RELIEF THAT COULD
BE PROVIDED BY ALLOWING US TO
PAY CURRENT MARKET RATES FOR
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
AND PERHAPS CREATE OUR OWN MICRO
GRIDS WE NEED TRUE OVERSIGHT OF
THE SAFETY PLANTS.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL POINTED
OUT THEY DON'T MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE FOLLOWING THOSE PLANS
MISTER GALLAGHER ANY TO MISSED
GALLAGHER TIME IS EXPIRED.
ONLY.
CAN WE BE ASSURED THAT WE WILL
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
THEY MAKE.
SAY NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
MR HOLDEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
[inaudible] FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFULNESS.
NOT JUST AS IT RELATES TO THIS
BILL.
BUT AS IT'S BEEN.
SPOKEN OUT BY MANY.
THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE
BEEN WRESTLING WITH FOR THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS.
NOT ON THE SURFACE.
BUT DEEP IN THE DETAILS AND
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BILL.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE SUBJECT OF
CONVERSATION.
OFFICIAL THROUGH A COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
HEARINGS.
AND PROBING INTO THE IMPACTS
[inaudible]
OF CONCEPTS [inaudible]
BUT ALSO [inaudible]
WORKING GROUP'S.
MEMBERS DEDICATED AND CONCERNED
ENOUGH TO GET TOGETHER AND SAY
WHAT CAN WE DO HOW CAN WE START
TO GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE LARGER PICTURE AND HOW
IT'S IMPACTING.
ON THE STATE OF AFFAIRS AS IT
RELATES TO WILDFIRES DEVASTATING
OUR COMMUNITY AND THE VICTIMS.
THE LEAVES IN ITS WAKE.
AND SO THIS BILL.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP
AND WE THANK YOU FOR THAT.
BROUGHT A LOT OF THE CONCEPTS
TOGETHER.
AND AS MANY OF YOU POINTED OUT
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED.
AND MANY OF THOSE CAN PROBABLY
BE ADDRESSED.
BEFORE THE END OF THE SESSION.
MANY OF YOU HAVE LEGISLATION
THAT STILL MOVING THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND NO ONE HAS EVER
SAID THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE.
THE SILVER BULLET.
OR THE FIX ALL.
BUT IT DOES TAKE US.
IN DRAMATIC LEAPS. TO WHERE WE
CAN STABILIZE CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT VICTIMS
[inaudible]
RATEPAYERS.
AND THE INDUSTRY THE KEEPS OUR
LIGHTS ON I WANT TO THANK.
MY JOINT AUTHORS.
HERE'S MY JOINT AUTHORS.
HAD BLLS THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE FUND.
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD LOOK
AT CREATING SOME TYPE OF A EARLY
ON OFFSET.
SO THEY HAD BILLS IN MOTION.
THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM CAME
TOGETHER AND TOOK THOSE CONCEPTS
AND GAVE SOME ADDITIONAL LIFE TO
IT.
SO WE ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
BUT WE DO STILL HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO.
AND NO ONE HAS EVER SAID THAT
THIS WAS A PERFECT BILL.
BUT I WANT TO ALSO THANK.
I RECOGNIZE MY COLLEAGUES.
TO HAVE EXPERIENCE THE
DEVASTATION OF WILDFIRES AND THE
IMPACT ON THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN THE THOMAS FIRE BROKE OUT
MY WIFE AND I WE GOT THE CAR WE
DROVE DOWN TO VENTURA
[inaudible]
WE SAW.
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM SANTA
BARBARA [inaudible]
IN MISSOURI.
WHO ARE DEALING WITH
CONSTITUENTS?
WHO WERE DEALING WITH?
FIRE LEADERSHIP TRYING TO
COORDINATE ACTIVITIES ALL THE
WHILE.
NOT ABLE TO BRIEF.
BECAUSE OF THE DENSITY THE SMOKE
THAT IN.
VELIT THEIR COMMUNITIES.
FIRE SMOKE THAT IMPACTS THE
ENTIRE STATE WERE ALL IMPACTED.
AND SO THIS MAKES US ONE
CALIFORNIA TRYING TO FIND A
SOLUTION THAT BENEFITS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND YES WE DO COME TOGETHER WE
HAVE DIFFICULT DECISIONS AND YES
SOMETIMES WE CAN BUILD CONSENSUS
AND YES SOMETIMES IT'S
BIPARTISAN AND SOMETIMES IT'S
NOT.
BUT ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
WITH THIS STATE IS DEALING WITH
THAT NO OTHER STATE IN THE UNION
IS DEALING WITH.
ONLY AUSTRALIA HAS THE
CONDITIONS THAT WE HAVE. TO TRY
TO MANAGE A CATASTROPHE OR THE
MAKINGS OF ONE ON A CONTINUOUS
BASIS WE'RE IN NEW FRONTS HERE.
WE HAVE TO ADAPT.
WE HAVE TO CREATE IDEAS WE HAVE
TO COME UP WITH OUR BEST
THINKING AND PLANS THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO MOVE FORWARD.
NOT PASSING THIS BILL WE DON'T
MOVE FORWARD.
TOMORROW THERE WILL BE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US.
TO TWEAK THOSE AREAS THAT NEED
TO BE TWEAKED.
EXPLORE FURTHER THERE OTHER
AREAS THAT NEED TO BE EXPLORED
THIRTY SECONDS MR HOLDEN.
I THINK WE WILL PRAY FOR EACH
OTHER.
WE PRAY FOR VICTIMS.
PEOPLE THAT WE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW.
BUT THERE CALIFORNIANS.
TODAY IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO ACT.
AND TO DO SOMETHING THAT CREATES
PREDICTABILITY GOING.
FOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AGO.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN THANK
YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
QUIRK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLLED TELL IT OUT I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS IT ON THE
URGENCY.
I SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
EIGHT ON THE MEASURE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO ENROLLMENT.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB
TWO NINE NINE SALAS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK IN ORDER THE
BILL BE RETURNED TO THE SENATE
FOR FURTHER ACTION.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM TO TAKE UP
AB ONE TEN AB ONE ELEVEN TODAY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENT
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
MR FLOOR FOR WHAT PURPOSE ARE WE
OBJECT AS FOR ROLL CALL VOTE MR
FLORA IS WITHHOLDING.
THIS IS A RULE SUSPENSION MOVED
BY CALLED AROUND.
SECOND BY MISTER GIBSON.
IT'S PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS
CORPORAL OF ON THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE.
VOTE ON THE RULE SUSPENSION IS
CALDERON TASKING FOR NINE MISTER
FLORA IS ASKING FOR NOW
[inaudible]
MR.
CALDERON ASKING HER NINE MISTER
FLORA NO CLERK WILL.
CLOSE A ROLL EYES FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN TO
TAKE UP A C. R. SEVENTEEN
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FIVE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONCURRENT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THERE
IS A PROCEDURAL RESOLUTION AT
THE DESK TO INVOKE THE
CONSTITUTION.
I ASK THAT WE TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTION RELATIVE TO ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION EIGHT BE ONE OF THE
CONSTITUTION FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DISPENSING WITH THE REQUIREMENT.
OF THREE READINGS OF THE BILL ON
THREE SEPARATE DAYS.
IS A PROPERLY REPORTS MR FLOOR
FOR PURPOSE ARE WE OBJECT AND
ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL REQUIRE A
ROLL CALL VOTE OF REGARDLESS BUT
YOUR OBJECTION.
IS NOTED.
VERSE THIS RESOLUTION IS NOT
DEBATABLE.
REQUIRES A ROLL CALL VOTE IT
TAKES FIFTY FOUR VOTES.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION.
EIGHT BE ONE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL READ.
THAT SENATE BILL THREE OH SEVEN
PRESENTS A CASE OF URGENCY AS
THAT TERM IS USED IN ORDER FOR
SECTION EIGHTY ONE OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND THE PROVISION OF THAT
SECTION REQUIRING THAT THE BILL
BE READ ON THREE SEPARATE DAYS
IN EACH HOUSE IS HEREBY
DISPENSED WITH AND IS ORDERED
THAT THE BILL BE PLACED UPON ITS
PASSAGE AND CONSIDERED ENGROSSED.
AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS.
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION AB ONE
RESOLUTION.
DISPENSING WITH THE THREE
READINGS ON THREE SEPARATE DAYS
REQUIREMENTS.
CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
BEVERAGES TAKES FIFTY FOUR THIS
IS PROCEDURAL.
IS NOW CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU WHAT I FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
THIS BILL IS READ A SECOND TIME
ON SECOND READING PREVIOUSLY.
CLERK WILL READ THE BILL FOR THE
THIRD TIME.
SENATE BILL THREE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR OFTEN ACTUALLY TO WATER.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AGAIN FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN TAKE UP
SB THREE OH SEVEN ROTH WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
MR FLOOR FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR WE
WILL HOLD UNANIMOUS CONSENT
NATURAL CALLED -- MISTER FLORA
IS WITHHOLDING MEMBERS THIS IS
ON THE ROLL SUSPENSION MOVE BACK
CALDERON.
SECONDED BY GIPSON CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR I
MR FLORA GNOMES COLORANTS ASKING
FOR AN I..
MISTER FLORA NOW [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THE TIME ON ICE FOR
THE FOR NO.
SEVENTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
THE CLERK WILL READ A BILL FOR
THE THIRD TIME.
SENATE BILL THREE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR ROBB AND ACTUALLY TO
WATER.
MS FREEMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE 2% SB THREE OH SEVEN
WHICH SEEKS TO PROTECT THE
FRAGILE MOJAVE DESERT ECO SYSTEM
FROM POSSIBLE OVER DRAFT BY
PROPOSE WATER PROJECT.
DUE TO CONCERN ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE PUMPING
PROPOSAL AND A SERIOUS CONFLICT
IN THE SCIENCE SURROUNDING THE
PROJECT.
THE BILL HITS THE PAUSE BUTTON
ON THE PROJECT TO ALLOW THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION WORKING
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. TO REVIEW AND
RECONCILE THE SCIENCE INVOKED SO
THAT IT ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RIGHT MAYBE
ESTABLISHED.
MOJAVE DESERT IS VERY FRAGILE
VERY IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA AND
ITS EXISTED WITH A VERY DELICATE
BALANCE FOR CENTURIES.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT WE
GET THE SCIENCE RIGHT AS WE
PRESERVE THE ENVIRONMENT WE
WON'T GET ANOTHER CHANCE WITH
THIS AREA.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHAT WE ALLOWED TO BE DONE IN
THE DESERT IS SUSTAINABLE
ALLSTATE COSTS ARE ANTICIPATED
TO BE MINOR OBSERVABLE OR
REIMBURABLE TO THE STATE AGENCY.
A SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY WITH FIFTY VOTES
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS FREEMAN MISTER OVER
LTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES THIS PROJECT IS
WITHIN MY DISTRICT AND SO.
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND LISTEN TO WHAT I HAVE
TO SAY ABOUT IT I SENT SPENT
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS
IN INVESTIGATING THIS PROJECT IN
VISITING THE PROJECT SITE.
FIRST OF ALL IT'S PROBABLY TOO
MUCH TO ASK.
THAT PEOPLE STOP MISPRONOUNCING.
THE THIS REGIONAL BY DESTRUCTIVE
STOPPER DOUBTS KITTIES IT'S
PRONOUNCED KATIE'S RHYMES WITH
HAITI'S AND IF YOU'VE EVER GONE
OUT THERE IN AUGUST YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND WHY.
ADDITIONALLY I HAVE TO ADMIT I
WAS VERY SKEPTICAL ABOUT THIS
IMAGINE SOMEONE COMING TO YOU
AND SAYING.
WE'D LIKE TO PUMP MILLIONS OF
GALLONS OF WATER A YEAR OUT OF
YOUR DISTRICT INTO OTHER
PEOPLE'S DISTRICT WOULD THAT BE
OKAY.
SO I WENT OUT TO THE PROJECT
SITE I MET WITH THE PROJECT
DIRECTORS AND THE MANAGERS.
THEY ANSWERED MY QUESTIONS AS
BEST THEY COULD IT WASN'T GOOD
ENOUGH FOR ME SO I ASKED TO
SPEAK WITH THE ENGINEERS I SPENT
MANY HOURS WITH THE ENGINEERS
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROJECT.
BASICALLY THIS AREA OF MY
DISTRICT IS AN ENORMOUS
WATERSHED IN WATER FLOWS
UNDERGROUND FROM THE HIGHER
ELEVATIONS DOWN INTO THE LOWER
ELEVATIONS.
AND EVENTUALLY THE WATER
PERCOLATES UP INTO THESE VAST.
DRY LAKE BEDS WHERE IT
EVAPORATES IN THE ATMOSPHERE
THESE LAKE BEDS ARE VERY BRINY
BECAUSE OVER THOUSANDS OF YEARS
THE WATER EVAPORATION OF THE
WATER HAS LEFT FOR A BLOCK
BEHIND MINERAL CONTENT.
SO THE MOMENT THAT WATER HITS
THAT BRIAN IT'S UNFIT FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION AFFECT ITS MUCH
SALTIER THAN THE OCEAN EVEN
BIRDS AND WILDLIFE CANNOT DRINK
IT.
YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD PEOPLE SAY.
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS.
REGARDING BIGHORN SHEEP AND THE
DRYING UP OF NATURAL SPRINGS BUT
I CAN TELL YOU HAVING BEEN OUT
THERE THAT IS COMPLETE.
HOGWASH.
THIS THOSE SITES ARE THOUSANDS
OF VERTICAL SPEED FEED COP THE
WATERSHED FROM THE EXTRACTION
SITE.
WHAT THE KATIE'S PROJECT IS
PROPOSING TO DO IS TO EXTRACT
THAT WATER BEFORE IT GETS TO THE
BRINY -- DRY LAKE BEDS AND
EVAPORATES INTO THE ATMOSPHERE.
SO IT CAN'T POSSIBLY HAVE ANY
AFFECT ON THESE UPSTREAM USES
[inaudible]
ALSO.
IF YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT MAYBE
THE OVER PUMPING OF WATER OUT OF
THAT SITE IF YOU'VE CONCERN OF
THE MAYBE THE ENGINEERS GOT THE
HYDROLOGY ROCK WHICH IS A
CONCERN THAT I HAVE.
YOU SHOULD TAKE SOME COMFORT AS
I DO IN THE FACT THAT WHEN THE
COUNTY OF SAN BENITO EXAMINE
THIS PROJECT.
THEY PUT A STRICT REQUIREMENT ON
THE TOPIC OF THE WATER AND IF
THE WATER LEVEL IN THE WATER
TABLE GETS ONE INCH BELOW.
WHAT THE KATIE'S ENGINEERS
PREDICT THAT IT WILL BE?
THEY HAVE TO IMMEDIATELY STOP
POPPING SO ANOTHER WORDS IF
THEY'RE WRONG ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THIS ISN'T GOING TO IMPACT
THE ENVIRONMENT THEY MUST
IMMEDIATELY STOP POPPING AND
WE'RE GOING TO STOP AND RE
EVALUATE THAT.
SO I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE OFTEN HAVE
DISAGREEMENTS DISCUSSIONS IN
THIS CHAMBER ABOUT WATER AND A
LOT.
OF THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS ARGUMENTS
ABOUT WATER BETWEEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO WE'VE HAD INTENSE
DEBATES ABOUT THE DELTA TITLES
AND ALL OF THESE CONVEYANCE
MECHANISMS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
A PROJECT THAT'S ALREADY LOCATED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT WILL
CREATE MILLIONS OF GALLONS OF
WATER FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION AND
WE'RE GOING TO TELL THEM NO.
BECAUSE OF THIS.
AND LASTLY I WANT YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THE TERRIBLE PRECEDENT
THAT WE'RE SETTING HERE THIS IS
A PROJECT THAT IS ALREADY GONE
THROUGH NUMEROUS LEVELS OF
INTENSE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL THEY HAVE
JUMP THROUGH EVERY SINGLE HOOP
THE GOVERNMENT COULD PUT IN
FRONT OF THEM.
SO WHAT WE'RE TELLING PEOPLE IF
WE PASS THIS BILL TODAY.
IS THAT NONE OF THAT MATTERS AND
THAT IF ENOUGH POWERFULLY
CONNECTED PEOPLE GET TOGETHER.
THEY CAN SPONSOR A BILL IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO STOP ANY PROJECT.
SO I ASK YOU IF WE SET THAT
PRECEDENT WHAT COMES NEXT.
IF A GROUP WANTS TO STOP AN
INFORMAL HOUSING PROJECT IN
THEIR DISTRICT.
IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD CAN THEY
DO THAT CAN THEY RUN A BILL LIKE
THIS PUT AN INVITE ADDITIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HURDLES IN PLACE
WHAT ABOUT THE ACCESS TO THE
COAST.
CAN WEALTHY PEOPLE ON THE COAST
LINE PETITION AND HAVE A BILL
BROUGHT FORWARD.
THIS IS NOT A DIRECTION THAT WE
WANT TO GO.
I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THIS CREATES MILLIONS
OF GALLONS.
OF WATER FOR HUMAN USE THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE LOST TO
EVAPORATION THE ATMOSPHERE.
IT'S HAD NUMEROUS ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS AND THERE ARE STRICT
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS I URGE A
NO VOTE ON THIS TERRIBLE
PRECEDENT SETTING BILL.
THEY WISH OBERNOLTE MISTER BROKE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE IN OPPOSITION SB THREE OH
SEVEN IT SEEKS TO STOP TO
KATIE'S PROJECT IN THE LIMITED A
WATER THEY CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF
FOUR THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S
ANNUALLY.
THE PROJECT IMPROVES LOCAL WATER
SUPPLY RIGHT LIABILITY AND
REDUCES DEMAND FOR OUR AREA FROM
DELTA AND COLORADO RIVER WATER --
KATIE'S AS BEEN SAID IS LOCATED
A SOLID CALIFORNIANS LESS ENERGY
NEEDED TO TRANSPORT THE WATER.
THIS MANAGES ENERGY DEMANDS
REDUCES A MICHELIN STABILIZES
WATER RATES THE PROJECT WOULD
CREATE A SUPPORT OVER FIFTY NINE
HUNDRED JOBS GENERATE MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE INCLUDING
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION PER YEAR
FOR THE SAME PER DO YOU KNOW
COUNTY BUDGET.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS REVIEW
HAS BEEN EXTENSIVELY.
HAP HAPPEN UNDER SEQUEL IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE SANTA
MARGARITA WATER AGENCY IN MY
DISTRICT CONDUCTED AN EIGHTEEN
MONTH PUBLIC REVIEW PROCESS.
WHICH HELD INFORMATION WORKSHOPS
EDUCATION SEMINARS AND PUBLIC
HEARINGS TO ENCOURAGE DIALOGUE
FROM THE COMMUNITY IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE FOLLOWING YEARS
OF ANALYSIS FIELD STUDIES IN
PUBLIC VIEW.
THE DISTRICTS CERTIFIED THE
FINAL E. ARE FEDERALLY IMPROVE
THE PROJECT UNDER SEQUEL.
THE FEDERAL E. I. R. SUMMARIZE
THE PROJECT WOULD AVOID ANY
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS TO DOES IT
RESOURCES INCLUDING CRITICAL
RESOURCES OF THE DESERT
ENVIRONMENT SUCH AS VEGETATION
MOUNTAIN WATER.
SPRINGS AND AIR QUALITY.
ALSO RESPONSIBLE AGENCY UNDER
SEQUENCE SAMBAR TO DO YOU KNOW
FACILITY TO REVIEW PROCESS OF
THE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
MONITORING IN MITIGATION PROJECT
IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AND THIRTEEN
THESE APPROVALS FOR CHALLENGING
COURT THESE CASES WITH WITHDRAWN
OR OTHERWISE SMIS.
AND SIX PRECEDED THE TRIAL
ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
TONIGHT ALL THE SEQUEL GAMES
AGAINST PROJECT AN UP HILL THE
PROJECTS REVIEWS.
AND APPROVALS THESE RULES WERE
APPEAL TO THE CALIFORNIA COURT
OF APPEALS AND WE'RE UP HELD IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE BILL WOULD
ADD TWO MORE REVIEWS THE SECRET
PROCESS AND SIMPLY DISREGARD TO
THROW SEQUEL PROCESS WHICH WE
CONSIDERED THE GOLD STANDARD.
AND WAS APPROVED IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WE NEED MORE
WATER PROJECTS NOT FEWER IN HERE
WE SET A PRECEDENT THAT THE
PROJECT IT'S GOING TO SEE C<c.cyan></c>
UP IN TEN YEARS AND SOMEBODY
COMES ALONG AND SAYS WELL THAT'S
NOT GOOD ENOUGH LET'S AT ANOTHER
STATE AGENCY.
SINCE THE LEGISLATIVE CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THIS PROJECT WE HAVE
LOST TWENTY BILLION GALLONS OF
EVAPORATED WATER.
THIS ALONG WITH THE PUBLIC THE
CELL PLAN IN MY DISTRICT.
WOULD MAKE A SELF RELIANT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT LOCAL DISTRICTS
IN THEIR CREATIVITY AND
INGENUITY IN THEIR PROJECTS AND
NOT HAVE STATE INTERFERENCE AS
THEY WORK TO INCREASE SUPPLY.
AND PRESERVE OUR VALUABLE WATER
RESOURCES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NOVO.
WITH YOUR FLORA YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE OH
SEVEN AND I'M NOT GOING TO STAND
FOR LONG BUT I WANT TO REITERATE
JUST A COUPLE QUICK POINTS.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION IN THE BUILDING
RIGHT NOW IN IN OUR CHAMBER.
BUT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY VERY DIRE
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT.
THE PRECEDENT THAT IT SETS. FOR
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US THEY HAVE
PROJECTS IN OUR DISTRICT.
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH SEQUEL.
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL -- REVIEWS THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT HAS GONE
THROUGH IT ALL.
HAS BEEN HELD UP IN A COURT OF
LAW.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A POLITICAL
FRIEND AND MONEY.
YOU CAN RUN PIECES OF
LEGISLATION TO JAM IT UP.
THE PEOPLE THAT OPPOSE THIS
PROJECT THEY DON'T WANT THIS
PROJECT TO MORE AND REFUSED TO
BE DONE THEY WANT IT DEAD.
IF THIS PROJECT DIES.
THE WATER COMES FROM PEOPLE FROM
MY DISTRICT IN THE PEOPLE NORTH
OF ME.
THE GOVERNOR'S MADE A VERY CLEAR
ABOUT A STATE WIDE WATER FIX
WHICH I SUPPORT WHOLEHEARTEDLY
WE CANNOT HAVE A STATEWIDE WATER
FIX IF WE CAN'T GET PROJECTS
LIKE THIS DONE.
COLLEAGUES IT IS LONG.
PAST TIME THAT WE QUIT ALLOWING
POLITICS TO KILL PROJECTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FLORA.
MISTER SPEAKER.
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL.
THREE ZERO SEVEN THIS IS THIS
ISSUE HAS CONCERNED ME SINCE THE
START OF THE SESSION AS IT
REPRESENTS THE INTERSECTION.
OF TWO ISSUES THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME. ONE IS
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT FOR
EVERYONE.
NO MATTER WHAT ECONOMIC GROUP
THEY BELONG.
TO THE OTHER IS PROVIDING SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR CALIFORNIANS.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE THAT WATER
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IT IS
DONE WITHOUT DAMAGE TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS BILL IS A WELL CONSIDERED
APPROACH TO DO JUST THAT.
IT MERELY SAYS ALL IT SAYS IS
THAT THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
CONSULTING WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
STORIES ON WILDLIFE AND WATER.
MUST SIGN OFF THAT'S IT THAT'S
ALL IT SAYS.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
SENATE ON THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY CO AUTHORS
THE MEMBER FROM GLENDALE.
THE MEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO THE
MEMBER FROM SAN RAFAEL THE
MEMBER FROM MONTEREY BAY.
AND A PARTICULAR I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THE MEMBER FROM OUR
LEADER WHO DEVOTED A LOT OF
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE.
BUT IS REPRESENTING THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSE WORK TODAY RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
THREE ZERO SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE WE WILL TAKE THAT AS THE
CLOSE.
QUIRK GLOBAL ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE -- CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELEPHONE EYES.
FORTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY TWO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING UP AB.
ONE TEN CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TEN BY SOME
MEMBER TEAM AND ACTUALLY TO THE
STATE BUDGET MAKING
APPROPRIATIONS THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELT.
MR TAKE YOU MAY OPEN.
THINKING BUT SPEAKER AB ONE TEN
A MAN'S THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT.
THE BILL PROVIDES TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO IMPLEMENT.
QUALIFIER MEASURES WHICH WE JUST
VOTED ON WITH REPORTING TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE.
BUDGET COMMITTEE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU FOR STAYING.
THE STRUGGLE TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE TOWN THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IT'S APPROPRIATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE UNDER THIS
TRAILER BILL WILL HELP THEM. TO
FULFILL THEIR ROLE IN MITIGATING
THE RISK OF WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S VERY SUPPORTABLE
LARGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS ROBIN OAKLEY
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE BUDGET ITEM
[inaudible]
QUIRK LIBERAL.
DESIRE BUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TALBOT EYES.
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL. TO THE SENATE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS AB.
ONE ELEVEN THEY WERE CORRECTION
MEMBERS IS THE CORRECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
ENROLLMENT ON THAT ITEM.
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE AB.
ONE ELEVEN CLOCK RATE ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE ELEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND ACTUALLY THE
WILDFIRE AGENCIES MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MR TANG IMAGEN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B.
R. ONE ELEVEN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL IT CREATES.
THREE NEW STATE ENTITIES THAT
WILL HELP IMPLEMENT A. B. TEN
FIFTY FOUR WHICH WE JUST
DISCUSSED.
THE FIRST IS THE WILD FIRE
SAFETY DIVISION IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHO WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WILD FIRE SAFETY
ACTIONS INVESTIGATIONS OVER THE
NEXT. TWO YEARS.
SECOND IS AS OF JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A NEW STATE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE CREATED THE
OFFICE OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
IN SAFETY.
THIS THEY WOULD ASSUME THE ROLE
OF OVERSEEING WILD FAR SAFETY
ACTIVITIES AND INVESTIGATE.
RELATED INVEST IN INVESTIGATIONS
RELATED TO ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND LASTLY THE CALIFORNIA.
CANDICE A CATASTROPHE RESPONSES
COUNCIL NOW COMPOSED OF NINE
MEMBERS WILL OVERSEE THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY.
IN THE WILD FIRE FUND
ADMINISTRATOR -- WE ODYSSEY WILL
BE APPROPRIATE A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE PC TO FUND THESE
ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH BY
JUST DISCUSSED WITHOUT A RESPECT
FOR US RIGHT NOW.
FAMOUS JAMES ROBERT ALTON THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE ELEVEN I DON'T
THINK IT'S AN EXAGGERATION TO
SAY THAT THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE
IS AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT. TO
LIFE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL DISTRICTS
LIKE THE ONE I REPRESENT.
THE STATE OF NEW STATE ENTITIES
THAT ARE CREATED IN THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL ARE IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS RECOGNIZING THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PREVENT THOSE
WILDFIRES IRISH AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD ONLY SEE
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
WELL OVER THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROTELLA VOTE EYES SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CAN CURTIN.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
ENROLLMENT.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS A C. R..
SEVENTEEN KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER --
WENT RELATIVE TO THE SERGEANT
RONALD RON LEE HE LISTA MORRELL
HIGHWAY.
MR WHEN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
A C. R. SEVENTEEN WHICH
DEDICATES A PORTION OF HIGHWAY
ONE A ONE IN HONOR OF INTER
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPUTY RON HILL
AS THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ADD IN
CO AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR DR OF THANK YOU.
MS OR ONE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS A DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL. ZERO TIGER BUT I
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IT.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP [inaudible]
AMENDMENTS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY THREE FILE ITEM. SIXTY
THREE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
COURT AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL THREE OH THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING NUMBER
OBERNOLTE.
MR OF AN OLD SANTEE MEMONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WERE CASKEY TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SB.
THREE OH THREE SB THREE OH THREE
AN AXE IMPORTANT DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSERVATIVES
THAT ARE FACING THE LOSS OF
THEIR HOMES THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFY THE COURTS
HAVE DISCRETION.
IN THE EXPENDITURE OF PUBLIC
FUNDS FOR THOSE.
I REQUEST THAT THE BILL GO OUT
TO PRINT AND BE BACK ON THE FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
THAT OBJECTION MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE A FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTY SB FIVE FIVE SEVEN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORKERY WITH AMENDMENTS SAMPLE
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GABRIEL.
MR GABRIEL ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE
AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR CLARIFYING
TECHNICAL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
BACK ON FILE.
WE ARE MOVING TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS A MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING
HEARING ON THE CLERK READ.
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
AS IN THE CURRENT VERSION ONE
HUNDRED BY SOMETHING NUMBER CHOI
AND OTHERS WILL TO THE PURPLE
HEART DAY.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS IS CONSENT
.
KIRK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE EYES SEVENTY
THREE NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED WE'RE GOING TO PASS
RETAIN.
ON THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
.
EVERYONE TO PASS RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE OF FOUR ONE OH FIVE
AND ONE OH SIX ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CLICK OR READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY RESOLUTION ONE OH SIX
HI SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO AS
ANNIKA RESOLUTION ONE ELEVEN I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO AS I MAKE
A RESOLUTION NINETY SEVEN I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SAMPLE.
SIXTY TWO I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO CYNICAL NINETY NINE I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SAMPLE TO
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO CYNICAL FOR SEVENTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY THREE NO SIR SENATE BILL
FIVE OH SIX I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY
NINE I SEVENTY THREE NO.
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY FIVE
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ELEVEN
HIGHS SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY JULY TWELVE THROUGH
FRIDAY AUGUST NINTH [inaudible]
RECESS.
MONDAY AUGUST TWELFTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.
A QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
THE GERMANS A MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR WE ARE AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE AT A GERMAN SOME MEMORY
REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE A
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION YOUR
COLLEAGUES.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN A MEMORY.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF JOANNE BOOZE AND MARK
AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE NAPA
COMMUNITY.
JOANNE PASSED AWAY EARLY IN THE
MORNING OF MAY TWENTIETH.
JOANNE WAS BORN IN ROSEBURG
OREGON AND RAISED ON THE BOOZE
AND MARK RANCH.
SHE NEVER LOST HER LOVE FOR THE
FARM.
SHE MOVED IN NAPA FIFTY YEARS
AGO WHERE SHE MERELY BECAME A
COMMUNITY LEADER.
SHE SERVED ON THE NAPA CITY
COUNCIL.
NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND COUNTLESS BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS INCLUDING THE
PLANNING COMMISSION COMMISSION
ON AGING AND AREA AGENCY ON
AGING.
SHE WAS A MENTOR AND FRIEND TO
MANY IN ALWAYS A STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR SPECIAL POPULATIONS.
JOANNE WAS A FORCE TO BE
RECKONED WITH.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY YOUR SISTERS
DALENE AND LEADER AND LONG TIME
FRIEND BEVERLEY WORDS AND
MULTIPLE FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES.
THE NAPA COMMUNITY IS
CELEBRATING THE LIFE AND LEGACY
OF JOY IN THIS SATURDAY JULY
THIRTEENTH A NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN A JOINING IN
THE MEMORY OF JOY AND WAS AND
MARK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS SAGER OCCURRING.
MS QUIRK SILVA AND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF CLEARER ROSALYN
PETERS HERNANDEZ WHO PASSED ON
MAY TWENTY SEVENTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN CLARA WAS BORN
OCTOBER SECOND NINETEEN THIRTY
EIGHT TO VERNAL AT POWERS AND
HELEN BERKELEY PETERS AND A COIN
ILLINOIS.
SHE WAS THE LAST OF EIGHT
CHILDREN CLARA TOUCHED MANY
LIVES AND LEAVES MANY LOVING
FAMILY MEMBERS TO MOURN HER
GLORIOUS LIFE.
CLEAR GRADUATED FROM TO COIN
TOWNSHIP HIGH SCHOOL IN PERRY
COUNTY ILLINOIS AND MOVED TO
FULLER.
TEN WITH HER SISTER SHE RECEIVED
AN A A DEGREE FROM FULLERTON
COLLEGE AND MARRIED RAOUL JOSE
HERNANDEZ ON APRIL.
TWENTY SIXTH.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT THEY HAD
TWO CHILDREN MARIA AND JOEY
HERNANDEZ.
CLEAREST SERVED IN SEVERAL
MINISTRIES WITH HER CHURCH THAT
WOULD BE AND ALSO BELONG TO THE
WOMEN'S BIBLE AND PRAYER GROUP.
ELLER DEGRADES CHOIR YOUTH AND
CHILDREN'S MINISTRY AND FEEDING
THE MINISTRY.
AND MANY OTHER SERVICE CLARA WAS
DEDICATED TO SERVING HER
COMMUNITY.
HER CAREER BEGAN AT BOEING'S
AUTOMATICS MISSILE SYSTEMS
DIVISION IN ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA
AND HER GROUP WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN THE SUCCESS OF THE HISTORIC
APOLLO ELEVEN SPACE MISSION.
WHEN THE COMPANY WAS ABSORBED BY
BOEING CLARICE PASSION FOR
SERVING AND HOW HELPING PEOPLE
BROUGHT HER TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA?
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WHERE SHE WORKED AS A
SUPERVISOR AND CONSULTANT FOR
YEARS IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS TELL
SHE RETIRED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY HELPED
HER TO FIND OUR TRUE CALLING SHE
OPENED HER HOME. FOR THOSE
NEEDING A PLACE TO STAY FEEDING
THE HOMELESS MENTORING YOUNG AND
SPENDING MANY MANY HOURS FUND
RAISING.
CLARA SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE
SOCIAL FULLER TO NON PROFIT IN
THE LATE.
SIXTIES AND EARLY SEVENTIES
AMBASSADORS AND WAS
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS THE
COOKIE LADY OF THE FOR TEN
CHAMBER OF CONGRESS NOW REMAIN
NAMES AT THE NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
CLARA ROSE WAS A VIBRANT FEISTY
FORCE OF LIFE THAT WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR COMPASSIONATE AND
UNIQUE MANNER OF LOVING HER
COMMUNITY AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK TO ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU AS QUIRK SILVA.
MR WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND SCOTT DE
BERRY.
SCOTT WAS LARGER THAN LIFE IN
STATURE HEART AND SERVICE TO HIS
COUNTRY AND COMMUNITY.
HE WILL BE MISSED BY MANY
INCLUDING HIS WIFE OF ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS MICHELLE HIS
DAUGHTER CASSIE.
WHO RECENTLY GRADUATED FROM THE
VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF'S ACADEMY?
HER FIANCE KYLE TIAS HIS SON
CHRISTIAN.
AND HIS GIRLFRIEND JESSICA.
RENTALS AND THEIR YOUNGEST SON
CHASE.
SCOTT SERVED HIS COUNTRY IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY FOR TEN YEARS
AND RETIRED TO CIVILIAN LIFE IN
VENTURA COUNTY.
WHERE HE WENT TO WORK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR TWENTY
TWO YEARS?
REACHING RETIREMENT IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFE SCOTT VOLUNTEERED IN
HIS COMMUNITY.
HE COACHED FOOTBALL AND BASEBALL
AND SIR FOR YEARS ON THE BOARDS
OF THE THOUSAND OAKS TITANS AND
TEAL LITTLE LEAGUE.
THREAT THROUGH COACHING HE
POSITIVELY AFFECTED THE LIVES OF
MANY MANY YOUNG PEOPLE INCLUDING
MY SON.
TEACHING THEM THE IMPORTANCE OF
TEAMWORK.
HARD WORK COMMITMENTS AND
OPTIMISM ALWAYS WITH A GREAT
SENSE OF HUMOR.
HE CARED DEEPLY ABOUT ALL THE
KIDS HE COACHED WHETHER THEY
WERE SUPER STARS ARE JUST
LEARNING THE BASICS.
YEARS LATER WHENEVER I RAN INTO
HIM IN TOWN THE FIRST THING HE
WOULD ASK WAS ABOUT MY SON HOUSE
LUKE DOING IS YOUR DOCTOR YET.
RELIGION WAS A CENTERPIECE OF
HIS LIFE HE WAS VERY INVOLVED
WITH THE LIGHT HOUSE CHURCH
SERVING AS THE DIRECTOR OF
SECURITY.
AND ON THE ASSURE TEAM.
SCOTT MICHELLE HAD FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THEIR YEARS
TOGETHER.
THEY WERE PART OF A PROGRAM
CALLED MENDING KIDS
INTERNATIONAL.
THEY HOSTED ILL OR DISABLED
CHILDREN FROM OTHER COUNTRIES IN
THEIR HOME.
AND CARED FOR THEM WHILE THEY
WENT THROUGH SURGERIES UNTIL
THEY WERE WELL ENOUGH TO RETURN
HOME.
SCOTT RECENTLY WENT ON A MISSION
TRIP TO UGANDA TO WORK WITH
CHILDREN AND WHILE THERE HIS
VIEW AND PERCEPTION.
OF FORGIVENESS GUILT.
AND LIFE WERE ALTERED FOR THE
BETTER.
SCOTT LIVED A LIFE IN SERVICE TO
HIS COMMUNITY.
AND HIS DEEDS AND LOVE FOR
OTHERS HAS FOREVER CHANGED ALL
WHO KNEW HIM I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN.
MR TROUT.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER IT IS WITH
IMMENSE SADNESS AND DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES THAT I RISE TO A
JOURNEY THE MEMORY OF SUSAN JOE
MARTINEZ.
A RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
ROSEMEAD SUSAN PASSED AWAY ON
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN
WHILE AT HOME AND SURROUNDED BY
FAMILY AND LOVED ONES.
SUSAN WAS BORN TO JO ANN
MARGARET HERNANDEZ ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIRST.
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX SHE WAS THE
THIRD OLDEST OF EIGHT CHILDREN.
SHE GRADUATED FROM OUR LADY OF
LAREDO HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND WAS LATER
SELECTED TO REPRESENT HER
COMMUNITY AS MISS EAST LA.
SHE MET HER HUSBAND ERNIE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND THEY
WERE LATER MARRIED ON JUNE.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE SUSAN AND EARNING RAISE
THREE CHILDREN CORINNE DANIEL
AND LISA JO AND INSTILLED IN
THEM A LOVE FOR EACH OTHER.
THE VALUE OF FAMILY AND A STRONG
FAITH.
OUTSIDE OF FAMILY SUSAN WAS
PASSIONATE ABOUT HER COMMUNITY
AND WORKING WITH CHILDREN SHE
WAS A RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
ROSEMEAD SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND SPENT
THIRTY THREE YEARS ****
PRESCHOOL TEACHER AT ROSEMEAD
PARK.
WHEN CITY RESTRUCTURING IMPACTED
TO HER POSITION AT THE PRESCHOOL
SHE STUDY TRAIN AND FOR SIXTY
YEARS?
PASSED THE CITY'S EXAM TO BECOME
A LIFEGUARD AT SIXTY YEARS OF
AGE.
SHE ALSO DEDICATED HERSELF TO
HER FACE.
SHE WAS A LONGTIME PARISHIONER
AND VOLUNTEER AT SEEING
ANTHONY'S CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
SAINT GABRIEL WAS SHE SPEND MORE
THAN THREE DECADES AS A MEMBER
OF THE CHURCH CHOIR.
SUSAN IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
HER THREE CHILDREN AND HER EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOINING IN
THE MEMORY OF SUSAN JEWEL
MARTINEZ THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAO.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS TO ADJOURN.
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR MAYES MOVES AND MISTER
SANTIAGO SECONDS [inaudible]
THE ASSEMBLY.
NOW INSURANCE FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN SUMMER RECESS PURSUANT
TO THE PROVISIONS OF JOINT ROLL
FIFTY ONE A THREE TO RECONVENE
ON MONDAY AUGUST TWELFTH. TWENTY
NINETEEN AT ONE PM.
WE ARE ADJOURNED
MAYES ON MOTION
TO SUSPEND THE RULES SEVENTY
SEVEN ON A. B. TEN FIFTY FOUR
FROM AND KNOWN TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
MOTION TO SUSPEND A ARE SEVENTY
SEVEN ON AB TEN FIFTY FOUR NO
NOT VOTING